This is Jocko podcast number 60 with Echo Charles and me,
Jocko Willink.
Good Evening Echo.
Good evening.
What I am about to relate is anything but a pleasant story in fact is so very
unpleasant that I cannot recommend anyone without a strong stomach to read it
for.
It is a story of such crime and horror as to almost be unbelievable.
The story of depredations of a horde of degraded criminals,
of incredible beastiality on a peaceful kindly law abiding people.
I believe it has no parallel in modern history.
Okay,
and that is a warning
that was written by a man by the name of George Fitch who was an American in the
city of Nan Qing China.
He was working for the y MCA in 1937 when the imperial Japanese army invaded.
And I'm going to tell you that that warning is not strong enough.
Okay?
And I know that many of you listened to this podcast with your children
and I am going to tell you right now this podcast,
this episode is not for children.
This episode is barely even for adults.
And I'm sure that some of you will not make it through this podcast
and I almost decided not to do it.
This podcast,
this episode is going to review a book called the Rape of Nan King by an author
by the name of Iris Chang.
And part of the reason that I decided that I had to cover this book
is because of the story that follows the story.
And that is of Iris Chang,
the author,
a bright,
beautiful,
intelligent,
successful,
and loving woman.
Yeah.
Who was consumed
by darkness.
And I will discuss her fate in a book that was written by her mother,
Ying Yang Chang in a book called the woman who could not forget.
And what happened in the city of Nan king is
it is beyond darkness.
It is,
it is beyond evil.
Okay.
Is pure savagery wanting savagery of the highest order?
And part of me thinks maybe it's best
if it is forgotten.
Maybe that's the best way to prevent it from happening again.
But part of me knows that that is wrong
and the only way to learn
is to study and to understand
and to try and banish.
Yeah.
This from our memories,
to me,
that leaves the door,
leaves the door open.
Okay.
For something like this to happen again somewhere.
Some time.
But I want to warn you again
that there are parts of this episode that are extremely graphic.
Yeah.
And I didn't put it all in there,
but I absolutely wanted people to understand that this is what happened and I
feel compelled to discuss it.
Okay.
Four,
four,
one for Iris Chang,
who in my mind sacrificed everything to tell the story
to help ensure that those who suffered all remembered
and also to ensure that the human race at large
has the knowledge,
has the warning that evil exists,
and that mankind is capable of becoming engulfed in that evil.
Okay.
And that man can act without mercy or remorse.
Or the slightest shred of humanity at all.
Go into the book
to prepare for the inevitable war with China.
Japan had spent decades training it's men for combat.
The molding of young men to serve and the Japanese military began early in life
and in the 1930s the Marshall influence seeped into every aspect of Japanese
boyhood.
Tory shops became virtual shrines to war selling arsenals of toy soldiers,
tanks,
helmets,
uniforms,
rifles,
anti aircraft guns,
bugles and Howard sirs memoirs from that time described pre adolescent boys
waging mock battles in the streets using bamboo poles as imaginary rifles.
Some even tied logs of wood on their back and fantasized about dying as human
bomb heroes in suicide missions.
Now I can tell you I grew up doing all that stuff.
We played war all the time,
all the time.
So I,
I don't find anything shocking about that.
Back to the book,
Japanese schools operated like miniature military units.
Indeed.
Some of the teachers were military officers who lectured students on their duty,
on their duty to help Japan fulfill its divine destiny of conquering Asia and
being able to stand up to the world's nations as a people second to none.
Now we're starting to get off course.
They taught young boys how to handle wooden models of guns and older boys.
How to handle real ones.
Textbooks became vehicles for military propaganda.
One geography book even use the shape of Japan as justification for expansion.
We appear to be standing in the vanguard of Asia,
advancing bravely into the Pacific.
At the same time,
we appear ready to defend the Asian continent from outside attack.
Teachers also instilled in boys hatred and contempt for the Chinese people
preparing them psychologically for a future invasion of the Chinese mainland.
One historian tells the story of a squeamish Japanese school boy in the 1930s
who burst into tears when told to dissect a frog.
His teacher slammed his knuckles against the boy's head and yelled,
why are you crying about one lousy frog when you grow up,
you'll have to kill 100 200 chinks.
Japanese minister of Education declared that schools were run not for the
benefit of the students,
but for the good of the country.
Okay.
Elementary school teachers were trained like military recruits with student
teachers housed in barracks and subject to harsh discipline and indoctrination.
In 1890 the imperial rescript on education emerged.
It laid down a code of ethics to govern not only students and teachers,
but every Japanese citizen.
Yeah.
The rescript was the civilian equivalent of Japanese military codes,
which valued above all obedience to authority and unconditional loyalty to the
emperor
in every Japanese school.
Copy of the rescript wasn't shrined with a portrait of the emperor and taken out
each morning to be red.
Okay.
It was reputed that more than one teacher who accidentally stumbled over the
wards committed suicide to atone for the insult to the sacred document.
Yeah,
so we've got a,
that's an 1890 by the way,
1890 so this is generations now that this is being plugged into the,
to the students' brains
and these things.
Okay.
You know when,
when we,
when we talk about students,
we talk about children,
we teach them generally freedom is the ultimate goal.
Freedom is the ultimate.
Okay.
The ultimate,
the ultimate thing to strive for,
the ultimate thing to defend his freedom.
And here they're getting taught that the ultimate thing was obedience to
authority and unconditional loyalty.
Back to the book.
It was common place for teachers to behave like sadistic drill sergeant slapping
children across the cheeks,
hitting them with their fists or bludgeoning them with bamboo or wooden swords.
Students were forced to hold a heavy,
heavy objects,
sit on their knees,
stand barefoot in the snow,
or run around the playground until they collapsed from exhaustion.
Okay.
There were certainly few visits to the schools by indignant or even concerned
parents.
The pressure to conform to our authority intensified if the school boy decided
to become a soldier.
Okay.
This is hazing and relentless and relentless pecking order usually squelched any
residual spirit of individualism within him.
Obedience was touted as a supreme virtue,
okay?
And a sense of individual self worth was replaced by a sense of value as a small
cog in the larger scheme of things to stablish the sublimation of individuality
to the common good superior officers of older soldiers slap recruits for almost
no reason at all,
or beat them severely with heaven,
wooden,
raw,
heavy wooden rods according to the author,
Toshio officers often justified unauthorized punishment saying,
I do not beat you because I hate you.
I beat you because I care for you.
Do you think I performed these acts with hands swollen and bloody in a state of
madness?
Some youths died under such brutal physical conditions.
Oh,
there's committed suicide.
Okay.
The majority became tempered vessels into which the military could pour a new
set of life goals.
So this is complete,
you know,
militant raising of children.
And what I want to note here is anybody that thinks you know what?
That probably produced some incredible warriors.
You're actually wrong.
Okay?
Did it,
did it produce warriors?
Yes it did.
But let's,
let's remember that these warriors that were raised in this manner,
when they had American soldiers and marines that had to face them when they were
in incredibly well dug in defensive positions and the Americans had to take
beach fronts and beach heads.
Okay.
The free thinking American soldier prove to be the better.
Yeah.
Back to the book,
training was no less grueling a process for aspiring officers above all,
the Japanese cadets were to adopt,
adopt a will,
which knows no defeat.
Okay?
So terrified where the cadets have any hint of failure.
That examination results were kept secret to minimize the risk of suicide.
Yeah.
So that's what,
again,
this was,
this was going all the way back to 1890.
So we've got 40 50 years' worth before we get into this,
where this,
uh,
massacre takes place.
Yeah.
Back to the book.
In the summer of 1937,
Japan finally succeeded in provoking a full scale war with China.
So Japan was now engaged in a war with China.
They went to Shanghai,
the Japanese invaded Shanghai,
you know,
big giant city.
And they,
they thought they were going to have no factor,
right?
Because they're getting told all the time that they're the best and they're the,
there's there,
you know,
the supreme warriors and all this.
Well,
going back to the book here,
Japanese military,
military leaders had boasted and seriously believe that Japan could conquer all
of mainland China within three months.
We got some arrogance going on here,
but when a battle in a single Chinese city alone,
that was Shanghai dragged from summer to fall,
and then from fall to winter,
it shattered Japanese fantasies of an easy victory.
Here,
this primitive people illiterate in military science and poorly trained had
managed to fight the superior Japanese to a stand still.
We're in Shanghai finally fell in November.
The mood of the imperial troops had turned ugly
and many say,
and many it was said lusted for revenge as they marched towards Nan King.
So they're on route now.
They had a hard time taking down Shanghai.
They got vengeance on their mind when they're going into the city of Nan King.
Back to the book.
Little was spared on the path to Nan king.
Japanese veterans remember rating tiny farm communities where they clubbed or
bay unaided.
Everyone in sight,
but small villages.
We're not the only casualties.
Entire cities were raised to the ground.
Consider the example of sue chow,
a city on the east bank of ty who lake,
one of the oldest cities in China.
It was prized for its delicate silk,
embroidery palaces and Temple Temple's.
It's canals and ancient bridges had earned.
It's earned the city.
It's western nickname.
As the Venice of China.
On November 19th,
on a morning of pouring rain,
a Japanese advanced guard marched to the gates of Soochow wearing hoods that
prevented the Chinese centuries from recognizing them once inside the Japanese
murdered and plundered the city for days burning down ancient landmarks and
abducting thousands of Chinese women for sexual slavery.
The invasion according to the China weekly review,
because the population of the city to drop from 350,000 to less than 500.
Okay.
But the worst was still to come.
Now there was a general that was sort of in charge of the,
uh,
the Japanese that were heading to,
to Nan king.
His name was general met Zooey and he seemed to have some semblance of honor to
him
and gave some pretty,
pretty good,
I would say benevolent type as benevolent as you can be when you're going into
war of orders.
So here's one of the things that he proclaimed the back to the book,
the entry of the imperial army into a foreign capital is a great event in our
history,
attracting the attention of the world.
Therefore let no unit enter the city in a disorderly fashion.
Let them know beforehand the matters to be remembered and the position of
foreign rights and interests in the walled city.
Let them be absolutely free from plunder.
He's given some pretty,
like I said,
about as benevolent orders as you could give.
That was Matsui.
Well unfortunately met sir.
We get sick and he can't be the leader,
although he kind of goes in and out of a leadership position as this is going
on.
There's a new guy that comes in and the new guy that comes in is actual royalty
named
prince a soccer.
Now,
prince,
Isaca gets word.
He starts to get to understand the situation that they're going into and he gets
told that,
yeah,
they're going to be,
when they take Nan king,
they're going to have about 300,000 Chinese troops to deal with.
Yeah,
and they'd get some preliminary word that it sounds like the,
the Chinese are ready to surrender.
They kind of hear that intelligence.
They have spies in there and whatnot.
Back to the book after a soccer heard this report.
It was said that his headquarters sent out a set of orders under his personal
seal marked secret to be destroyed.
We now know that the message of these orders was clear.
Kill all captives.
Yeah,
and they actually do have a copy of an order that came out
and this was on December 13th,
1937 the Japanese 66th battalion received the following command.
I'm not going to read the whole thing,
but here's parts of it.
Battalion Battle reporter at zero at two zero zero received order from the
regiment commander to comply with or orders from the brigade commanding
headquarters.
All prisoners of war are to be executed.
Method of execution,
divide the prisoners into group of a dozen shoot to kill separately goes on to
give some details about who's supposed to run this and then it continues back to
the book.
The vicinity of the imprisonment must be heavily guarded.
Our intentions are absolutely not to be detected by the prisoners.
Every company is to complete preparation before zero 500 executions are to stop.
Start promptly by that time and action is to be finished by seven 30
so there you go.
Straight up orders,
they're going to kill everyone.
And
it's very important to note here that says our intentions are absolutely not to
be detected,
so they weren't gonna make it very clean desk,
dine and keep the Chinese from knowing that they were going to kill them all.
Back to the book,
there was a ruthless logic to the order.
The captives could not be fed,
so they had to be destroyed.
Killing them would not only eliminate the food problem,
but diminish the possibility of retaliation.
Moreover,
dead enemies could not form up into guerrilla forces.
So they have their orders,
they go in and the begin the operation.
And here we go.
Back to the book.
All of this was easier to achieve than the Japanese had in tipis and t had
anticipated.
Resistance was sporadic.
Indeed,
it was practically nonexistent having thrown away their arms when attempting to
flee the city.
As the Japanese closed in,
many Chinese soldiers simply turned themselves in hoping for better treatment.
Once the men surrendered and permitted their hands to be bound,
the rest was easy.
So the Chinese give up their weapons
and allow themselves to be taken.
Not a good idea.
Now we're going to go to a quote from a Japanese soldier
named a,
it was funny yet pittable when I imagined to how they gathered whatever white
cloth they could find attached it to a dead twig and marched forward just to
surrender.
I thought,
how could they become prisoners with the kind of force that they had?
More than two battalions and even without trying to show any resistance,
there must have been a considerable number of officers for this many troops,
but not a single one remained all of them having slipped away and escaped.
I thought,
although we had two companies and those 7,000 prisoners had already been
disarmed,
our troops could have been annihilated had they decided to rise up and revolt.
And I
didn't go through too much of this,
but it was a chaotic scene when the Chinese who realized what was going to
happen and as that indicated,
a lot of the senior leadership,
they fled the city.
And so it left these soldiers there now with no leadership and what are they
going to do?
And you know,
the Japanese did psychological warfare on them and drop leaflets that said,
hey,
if you surrender,
you'll be treated well.
We have rice for you.
And that's what they did.
They lied,
of course.
Okay.
Back to the book.
When the Japanese military received orders on December 17th to kill prisoners,
they proceeded with extra caution that morning the Japanese announced that they
were going to transport the Chinese prisoners to a small island in the middle,
in the middle of the Yangtze River.
They explained to the captives that they needed to take special precautions to
move for the move and bound the captives,
hands behind their backs.
A task that took all morning and most of the afternoon,
sometime between four and 6:00 PM the Japanese divided the prisoners into four
columns and marched them to the west,
skirting the hills and stopping at the river bank.
After three or four hours of waiting and not knowing what was going on,
the prisoners could not see any preparations for car crossing the river.
The corporal wrote,
it was going dark.
They did not know that Japanese soldiers already in circled them in a crescent
formation along the river and that they were insights of many machine guns.
By the time the,
by the time the executions began,
it was too late for the Chinese to escape.
Yeah.
Suddenly all kinds of guns fired at once.
Okay.
Korea Ricci wrote the sound of the firearms mingled with the desperate yelling
and screams for an hour.
The Chinese struggled and thrashed about desperately until there were few sounds
coming from the group.
Okay.
From evening until dawn,
the Japanese Bay and edit the bodies one by one.
And that scene took place over and over and over again because what they did is
they indicated,
and they're not in that order,
if you missed it,
they separated the groups.
So they had them captured inside the city and then they took them in small units
of 30 40 Chinese soldiers tied their hands and said,
yep,
we're going to transport you.
And they did this all over the city at the same time,
coordinated and then took them out to different places outside the city and
killed them.
But it wasn't only the soldiers that they did this to back to the book.
After the soldiers surrendered on mass,
there was virtually no one left to protect the citizens of the city.
Knowing this,
the Japanese poured into Nan King on December,
1319 37 occupying government buildings,
banks and warehouses,
shooting people randomly in the streets,
many of them in the back as they ran away using machine guns,
revolvers,
and rifles,
the Japanese fired at the crowds of wounded soldiers,
elderly women and children who gathered in the north and central roads and
nearby alleys.
They also killed Chinese civilians in every section of the city.
Tiny lanes,
major boulevards,
mud dug outs,
government buildings,
city squares,
okay.
As victims toppled to the ground moaning and screaming,
the streets,
alleys and ditches of the fallen capital ran rivers of blood.
Much of it coming from people barely alive with no strength left to run away.
Okay.
The Japanese systematically killed the city dwellers as they conducted house to
house searches for Chinese soldiers and Nan King.
But they also massacred the Chinese and nearby suburbs and countryside corpse is
piled up outside the city walls along the river by ponds and lakes and on hills
and mountains.
Okay.
In villages,
near Nan King,
the Japanese shot down in a young man who passed under the presumption that he
was likely to be a former Chinese soldier.
Okay.
But they also murdered people who could not possibly be Chinese soldiers,
elderly men and women,
for instance,
if they hesitated or even if they fail to understand orders,
which would deliver it in Japanese language.
And obviously not every Chinese person spoke Japanese.
So this is now just a full on killing spree.
And I'm going to read a section here.
There was,
there was military war correspondents that were there from the Japanese
military.
And I will read this one is from,
uh,
military war correspondent named Yukio Amata.
And he saw the Chinese Brit,
uh,
prisoners being brought and lined up along the river
back to the book.
Those in the first row were beheaded.
Those in the second row,
we're forced to dump the severed bodies into the river before they themselves
were beheaded.
The killing went on nonstop from morning until night,
but they were only able to kill 2000 persons in this way.
The next day,
tired of killing in this fashion,
they set up machine guns through of them,
raked across fire at the lined up prisoners rat tat tat tat triggers were
pulled.
The prisoners fled into the water,
but no one was able to make it to the other shore.
Systematic murder of everyone is basically what we're dealing with
and when they got their momentum going on,
the extermination of most of the men.
Okay.
They turn their attention to the women.
Back to the book,
women suffered the most tacker,
Coro Kozew,
a former soldier and the hundred and 14th division of the Japanese army in
Nanking recalled,
no matter how young or old,
they all could not escape the fate of being raped.
We sent out coal trucks to the city streets and villages to seize a lot of women
and then each of them was allocated to 15 to 20 soldiers for sexual intercourse
and abuse,
surviving Japanese veterans claim that they,
that the army had officially outlawed rape of enemy women,
but rape remained so deeply embedded in Japanese military culture and
superstition that no one took the rules seriously.
Many believe that raping virgin would make them more powerful in battle.
Soldiers were even known to wear amulets made from the pubic hair of such
victims believing that they possessed magical powers against injury.
Yeah,
the military policy forbidding rape only encouraged soldiers to kill their
victims afterwards.
During an interview for the documentary in the name of the emperor as you must
Shiro,
a former Japanese soldier spoke candidly about the process of rape and murder in
Nan king.
Okay.
We took turns raping them.
It would be all right if we only rape them.
I shouldn't say all right,
but we always stabbed and killed them because dead bodies don't talk.
Tacker coral Kozo shared a zoom has bluntness and discussing the issue after
raping.
We would also kill them.
He recalled these women would start to flee.
Once we let them go,
then we would bang,
shoot them in the back and finish them up.
According to surviving veterans,
many of the soldiers felt remarkably little guilt about this.
Okay.
Perhaps when we were raping her,
we looked at her as a woman,
a Zuma wrote,
but when we killed her,
we just thought of her as something like a pig.
So
where,
where does this mindset comes from that permits this kind of behavior.
When you go into the book,
the Japanese soldier was not simply hardened for battle in China.
He's hardened for the task of murdering Chinese combatants and noncombatants
alike.
Okay?
Indeed,
various games and exercises were set up by the Japanese military to numb it's
men to the human instinct against killing people who are not attacking.
For example,
on the way to the capitol,
Japanese soldiers were made to participate in killing competitions,
which were avidly covered by the Japanese media,
like sporting events.
The most notorious one appeared in the December 7th issue of the Japan advisor
under the headline sub lieutenants race to fell 100 Chinese running close
contest,
sublieutenant,
Mukai Toshiaki and sublieutenant Noda to Kishi.
They were in a contest friendly contest to see which one of them will first fell
100 Chinese individuals,
individuals sword combat before the Japanese forces completely occupied Nan king
there.
Well in the final phase of their race,
running almost neck to neck
on Sunday,
December 5th the score according to ash aside,
he was sublieutenant Mukai 89 and sublieutenant noda 78
and just to give some more context on this,
these were just lining people up and chopping their heads off.
That's what this was just lining up civilians and let's see who can get to 150
or a hundred first
back to the book.
A week later,
the paper reported that neither man could decide who had passed the hundred mark
first,
so they up the goal to one 50
Mkhize blade was slightly damaged in the competition that Japan adviser
reported.
He explained that this was the result of cutting a Chinese.
In half helmet and all
the contest was fun.
He declared
another Japanese soldier talking about his experience.
Tominaga shows though wrote,
we made them like this.
Good sons,
good daddy's good.
Elder brothers at home were brought to the front to kill each other.
Human beings turned into murdering demons.
Everyone became a demon within three months.
In interview after interview Japan,
Japanese veterans from the Nanking Massacre Massacre reported honestly that they
experienced a complete lack of remorse or sense of wrongdoing even when
torturing helpless civilians.
Nakatomi Hakuto spoke candidly about his emotions in the fallen capitol.
Quote,
I remember being driven in a truck along a path that had been cleared through
piles of thousands and thousands of slaughtered bodies.
Wild dogs were gnawing at the dead flesh as we stopped and pulled a group of
Chinese prisoners out of the back.
Then the Japanese officer proposed a test of my courage.
He an sheath,
his sword spat on it and with a sudden mighty swing.
He brought it down on the neck of a Chinese boy cowering before us.
The head was cut clean off and tumbled away on the group as the body slumped
forward.
Blood spurting out in two great gushing fountains from neck.
The officer suggested I take the head home as a souvenir.
I remember smiling proudly as I took his sword and began killing people.
Few know that soldiers in paled babies on bay and nets and toss them still alive
into pots of boiling water.
They gang raped women from ages of 12 to 80 and then killed them when they could
no longer satisfy sexual requirements.
I be headed people,
starve them to death,
burn them and buried them alive over 200 and all.
It is terrible that I could turn into an animal and do these things.
There are really no words to explain what I was doing.
I was truly a devil.
Beyond those situations,
torture was also completely common.
Yeah,
and here's what the book says.
The torture that the Japanese inflicted upon the native population at Nan king
almost suppresses,
suppresses the limits of human comprehension.
Here are only a few examples.
Live burials,
the Japanese directed burial operations.
With the precision and efficiency of an assembly line,
soldiers would force one group of Chinese captives to dig a grave,
a second group to bury the first and then a third group to vary the second and
so on.
Some victims were partially buried to their chest or next so that they would
endure further agony such as being hacked to pieces by swords or run over by
horses and tanks,
mutilation the Japanese,
not only disemboweled decapitated and dismembered victims,
but performed more excruciating varieties of torture throughout the city.
They nailed prisoners to wooden boards and ran over them with tanks,
crucified them to trees and electrical posts,
carve long strips of flesh from them and use them for bayonet practice.
At least 100 men reportedly had their eyes gouged out and their noses and ears
hacked off before being set on fire.
Well,
another group of 200 Chinese soldiers and civilians were stripped naked,
tied to columns and doors of a school and then stabbed by special needles with
handles on them in hundreds of points along their bodies including mouth's
throats and eyes,
death by fire.
Okay.
The Japanese subjected large crowds of victims to mass incineration,
a Japanese soldier bound Chinese captives together 10 at a time and pushed him
into a pit where there were sprayed with gasoline and ignited
on taping road.
The Japanese ordered a large number of shop clerks to extinguish a fire,
then bound them together with rope and threw them into the blaze.
Japanese soldiers even devised games with fire.
One method of entertainment was to drive mobs of Chinese to the top.
Stories are roofs of buildings,
tear down the stairs and then set the bottom floors on fire.
Many such victims committed suicide by jumping out of windows or off rooftops.
Okay.
Another form of amusement involve dowsing victims and fuel shooting them and
watching them explode into flame.
In one infamous incident,
Japanese soldiers forced hundreds of men,
women,
and children into a square,
soak them with gasoline and then fired on them with machine guns.
Death by ice.
Thousands of victims were intentionally frozen to death during the rape of Nan
King.
Okay.
For instance,
Japanese soldiers forced hundreds of Chinese prisoners to march to the edge of a
frozen pond where they were ordered to strip naked,
break the ice,
and plunged in the water to go fishing.
Their bodies hardened into floating targets that were immediately riddled with
Japanese bullets.
In another incident,
the Japanese tied up a group of refugees,
flung them into a shallow pond and bombarding them with hand grenades causing an
explosive shower of blood and flesh
death by dogs.
One diabolical means of torture was to bury victims to their waist and watched
them get ripped apart by German shepherds.
Witnesses saw Japanese soldiers strip a victim naked and direct German shepherds
to bite sensitive areas of his body.
The dogs not only ripped open his belly,
but jerked out his intestines along the ground for a distance.
The incidents mentioned above are only a fraction of the methods that the
Japanese used to torment.
They're victims.
The Japanese saturated victims and acid in paled babies with bayonets hung
people by their tongues.
One Japanese reporter who later investigated the rape of Nanking learned that at
least one Japanese soldier toward the heart and liver out of a Chinese victim to
eat them.
Even genitals apparently were consumed.
A Chinese soldier who escaped from Japanese custody saw several dead people in
the streets with their penises cut off.
He was later told that the penis is were sold to Japanese customers who believe
that eating them would increase versatility.
Okay.
With regards to the fate of the women,
they don't know how to determine the exact number of the women that were raped.
Hey Nan king,
but
they do know that it was almost a universal.
Okay.
Back to the book,
the Japanese raped Nan king,
women from all classes,
farm wives,
students,
teachers,
white collar and blue collar workers,
wives of y,
Ymca employees,
university professors,
even Buddhist nuns,
some of whom were gang raped to death
and they were systematic in their recruitment of women.
And Nan King.
Japanese soldiers searched for them constantly as they looted homes and drag men
off wretch execution.
Some actually conducted door to door searches,
demanding money and young girls.
Chinese women were raped in all locations and at all hours.
Okay.
An estimated one third of all rapes occur during the day.
Survivors even remember soldiers prying open the legs of victims to rape them in
broad daylight in the middle of the street and in front of crowds of witnesses.
No place was too sacred for rape.
The Japanese attacked women and nunneries churches and Bible training schools.
17 soldiers raped one woman succession in a seminary compound.
Yeah.
Old Age was no concern to the Japanese matrons,
grandmothers and great grandmothers and dirt repeated sexual assaults.
Yeah.
Or Japanese soldier who raped a woman of 60 was ordered to clean the penis by
her mouth.
When a woman of 62 protested to soldiers,
that was,
she was too old for sex.
They rammed a stick up in style at her.
Instead.
Many women in their eighties were raped to death and at least one woman in that
age group was shot and killed because she refused.
A Japanese soldiers advances.
If the Japanese treatment of old women was terrible,
their treatment of young children was unthinkable.
Little girls were raped,
so Butte brutally that some could not walk for weeks afterwards.
Many required surgery,
others died.
Chinese witnesses saw Japanese rape girls under 10 years of age in the streets
and then slash them and half by sword.
In some cases,
the Japanese sliced open the Vaginas of preteen girls in order to ravish them
more effectively.
Even in advanced stages of pregnancy,
did not render women immune to assault.
The Japanese violated many who are about to go into labor or in labor or who had
given birth only a few days earlier.
One victim who is nine months pregnant was raped,
suffered not only stillbirth,
but a complete mental collapse.
At least one pregnant woman was kicked to death.
Still more gruesome was the treatment.
A lot of does some of the unborn children of these women
after gang rape,
Japanese soldiers sometimes slashed open the bellies of pregnant women and
ripped out the fetuses for amusement
during the mass rape.
The Japanese destroyed children and infants often because they were in the way
I witness's report
describe children and babies suffocating from close,
stuffed in their mouth's or bayoneted to death because they wept as their
mothers were being raped.
American and European observers of the rape of Nanking recorded numerous entries
like this one
February 3rd about 5:00 PM at Chuang Tzu who sang three soldiers came and forced
a woman to throw away her baby.
After raping her,
they went away laughing.
Perhaps one of the most brutal forms of Japanese entertainment was the
impalement of Vaginas in the streets of Nan King.
Corpses of women lay with their legs splayed open there,
orifice pierced by wooden rods,
twigs and weeds.
It's painful.
Almost mind numbing to contemplate some of the other objects that were used to
torment the Nan king.
Women who suffered almost unendurable or deals.
For instance,
one Japanese soldier who raped a young woman for us to beer bottle into her and
shot her.
Another rape victim was found with a golf stick rammed into her
and on December 22nd at a neighborhood near the gate of Tongan men,
the Japanese raped a barber's wife and then stuck a firecracker in her vagina.
It blew up and killed her,
okay?
Not all the victims were women.
Chinese men were often sodomized,
are forced to perform a variety of repulsive sexual acts in front of laughing
Chinese soldiers or Japanese soldiers.
Okay.
At least one Chinese man was murdered because you refuse to commit necrophilia
with the corpse of a woman in the snow.
The Japanese also delighted and trying to course men who had taken lifetime vows
of celibacy to engage in sexual intercourse.
A Chinese woman had tried to disguise herself as a man,
try and pass through the gates of Nan King,
but Japanese guards who systematically searched all passing pedestrians by
groping at their crotches,
discovered her true sex
gang,
raped,
followed at which time a Buddhist monk had the misfortune to venture near the
scene.
The Japanese tried to force him to have sex with a woman they had just raped.
Yeah.
When the monk pro protested,
they castrated him causing the poor man to bleed to death.
Some of the most sore it instances of sexual torture involve the degradation of
entire families,
the Japanese Jiu sadistic pleasure enforcing Chinese men to commit incest
fathers to rape their own daughters,
brothers,
their sisters,
sons,
their mothers.
A Chinese battalion commander stranded in Nan King for three months after the
city fell,
saw or heard of at least four or five instances in which the Japanese ordered
sons to rape their mothers.
Those who refused were killed on the spot.
His report,
a substantiated by the testimony of a German diplomat who reported that one
Chinese man who refuse to rape his own mother was killed with Saber strokes and
that his mother committed suicide shortly thereafter.
Yeah.
Those who defied the Japanese were often found later with their eyes torn out,
their noses,
ears,
and breasts cut off.
Okay.
As I said,
this is pure evil
and
I don't know what else to say.
Yeah,
no,
I'm going to the book here.
It's hard to talk about a bright spot in the horror that is the rape of Nanking.
But if one can,
it is surely to shine a light on the actions of a small band of Americans and
Europeans who risked their lives to defy the Japanese invaders and rescue
hundreds of thousands of Chinese refugees from almost certain extermination.
The courageous men and women created the International Committee for the Nanking
Safety Zone.
So this is,
you know,
amongst obviously this just most sadistic and heinous evil.
There were some Americans and some Europeans that lived and worked in Nan king.
And you gotta remember this is 1937 so it wasn't a world war yet.
The,
there was Germans there,
a Napkin and Nan king,
there was Americans there,
Nan King.
And when this started to happen,
there was several of them who basically formed an area where it said,
hey,
you know,
this is a safe zone.
And one of them interestingly was a German.
It was a Nazi.
Yeah.
So there is a Nazi who they ended up calling the Living Buddha of Nan and king.
Okay.
And so
this,
this individual,
um,
John Rabe was,
he risked his life to set up this,
the safety zone.
And actually,
no,
he was,
uh,
like I said,
he was a Nazi,
but he had spent much time in Nan king did.
He had all these Chinese friends and you know,
according to this,
to the background on him,
you know,
he's there in 19,
he's been there for many years and I don't know what year he got there,
but he's not familiar with what's going on with the actual Nazi party back in
Germany.
He's disconnected.
I mean there's,
you know,
this is whatever,
there's no internet.
He's not watching TV.
He doesn't know what's going on.
So he was just sort of sort of there.
And Oh,
the prominent party in Germany is the Nazi party.
Oh.
And I'm a diplomat,
so I guess I'm a Nazi.
And,
but when he,
you know,
he sounded like he was a guy that was a benevolent guy.
He actually went out into town and literally stop rapes from happening himself.
And what's interesting is,
and this,
this to me,
he set up that you could see what they thought of the Chinese people is that all
he would do is go out and speak,
stop.
And He,
he had the Nazi armband or what he had Nazi the swastika and when they saw that
they would listen to them.
And so,
I mean he still like he was a white guy and they,
they clearly listened to him and were kind of afraid of him.
And yet,
you know,
obviously they had zero less than zero respect for the Chinese people.
And so,
so he actually wrote a letter as well to Hitler explaining what was going on.
And you know,
there's,
there's no one knows if Hitler actually ever read it.
It sounds like he read it and ignored it.
But one of the most interesting and important pieces of what John Raved did is
he,
he kept a journal,
a detailed journal of what had happened.
So a lot of the stuff that I just quoted,
which I know is,
is horrible.
He was the guy,
he's one of the rare people that that wrote it down.
And made sure that P,
that it was going to be recorded.
And actually the,
the,
that diary didn't get really discovered and uncovered until much later until
really,
and,
um,
I was,
Chang is the one that sort of popularized and,
and took this journal and made it into a real document that explained what had
happened there.
So that's,
you know,
again,
this,
this John Rabe,
you know,
let's,
let's even in all that darkness,
there was people that stepped up and spoke against it.
Another one was a guy named by the name of Robert Wilson and he was actually
grew up in Nan king and he was a Methodist missionary,
but he had been left Nan king and gone back to America.
He went to Princeton and then he went to Harvard medical school.
And when he got done with all of the schooling and instead of staying in
America,
he went back to Nan king to become a surgeon in Nan king.
And he was him along with John Rabe.
These were the guys that went out and set up this protective zone and did all
kinds of,
you know,
it's,
it's sort of like a Schindler's list scenario.
No,
they were helping soldiers get rid of their papers and give them clothes.
They didn't look like Chinese soldiers sheltering the women.
Bring in setting up a places where the women can hide in the addicts of the
buildings.
That's what they were doing.
And it's the only thing that's,
well I guess not different,
but you know,
it's different in the fact that they could get away with it because we weren't
at war with the Japanese.
And so this Guy Wilson was,
was a surgeon.
So not only was he trying to protect people,
he was doing surgery on them all the time,
trying to get them to try to save them from these devastating wounds that they
had.
He also kept a really detailed diary,
which again,
these these,
and this is part of the whole
kind of genesis of this book,
is that,
and I'll get to this later,
but
the,
you know,
you've heard of like Holocaust deniers of the Holocaust didn't happen.
The world,
it's the same thing with this event.
People say,
oh,
it wasn't that bad.
You know,
it wasn't that big of a deal that will,
you know,
there were some killing.
So there was people that said that,
you know,
some Japanese nationalists and said,
no,
that didn't really,
wasn't really that bad.
It was provoked or whatever they're going to say.
And these documents,
these,
these documents that corroborate all this information,
we're truly important.
Going back to the book here,
one of the worst scenes,
Nielsen saw net.
Wilson saw Nan king a scene he would remember for the rest of his life,
a massive gang of Ugh,
massive gang rape of teenage girls in the street.
A group of young women between the ages of 15 and 18 were lined up by Japanese
and then raped in the dirt,
one after the other by an entire regiment.
Some hemorrhaged and died while others killed themselves shortly afterwards.
But the scenes in the hospitals were even more horrifying than those in the
streets.
Wilson was mortified by the women who came to the emergency room with their
bellies ripped open by the charred and horribly disfigured men whom the Japanese
tried to burn alive and by numerous other horrors.
He had barely had time to describe on paper.
He told his wife that he would never forget a woman whose head was nearly caught
off teetering from a point on her neck.
The morning came this morning,
and this is quote this morning,
another woman came in a sad plight and with a terrible story,
a hospital volunteer wrote of this woman in his diary in January 3rd,
1938 she was one of the five women whom the Japanese soldier had taken to one of
their medical units to wash their clothes to buy day and be raped by night.
Two of them were forced.
The two of them were forced to satisfy from 15 to 20 men and the prettiest one
as much as 40 each night.
This one who came to us had been called off by three soldiers into an isolated
place where they attempted to cut off her head.
Okay.
The muscles of the neck had been cut,
but they failed to sever the spinal cord.
She feigned death,
but dragged herself to the hospital,
another of the many to bear witness to the brutality of the soldiers,
so Wilson just saw complete horrors.
Then back to the book,
he operated for free because few patients had money to pay him,
but the surgeries exactly at a terrible price on his own health.
In the end,
his family believes that the old,
only his faith as a devout Methodist combined with his love for China gave him
the courage to survive the rape of Nan King.
Okay.
Another one of these Europeans in this case,
American Western or I should say was veal.
Amina Voltron or mini Voltron as they called her as by occupation.
Head of the education department,
Dean of studies at Guinn Ling Women's arts and Science College was one of the
few Western women in the city during the first few weeks of the Nanking
massacre.
Years later,
she would be remembered not only for her courage and protecting thousands of
women from Japanese soldier,
but also for the diary.
She kept a diary that some historians believe will eventually be recognized,
much like the diary of Anne Frank for its importance in illuminating the spirit
of a single witness during the holocaust of war
Voltron,
the daughter of a blacksmith was 51 years old in 1937 raised in the tiny farming
community of or Illinois.
She went to live with neighbors when her mother died.
Despite the impoverishment of her childhood,
she was able to work her way through school,
graduating with honors in 1912 from the University of Illinois at Urbana,
Urbana,
champagne,
so just again a of a western or in this case in American and she had the
opportunity to maybe escape,
but she stayed in Nan king.
Back to the book with most of the Faculty gone from Nan King,
most of the abandoned their homes to flee to cities like Shanghai,
Shin Cu and share Schwann Voltron was now the acting head of the institution.
She labored to prepare for the campus for female refugees and to evacuate
wounded soldiers from the area to disguise their identity.
She burned their military papers and carpets and the college incinerator under
her direction.
Furniture was moved into attics.
Safes were emptied,
dorms were cleaned,
and valuables were wrapped in oil,
paper and hidden.
Meanwhile,
posters,
signs and arm bands for the Ne Nan King Safety Zone were created and distributed
among the volunteers.
Here's talking about a specific day.
The following day,
December 17th,
1937 was even worse.
The migration of women into giggling only intensified as the Japanese soldiers
flooded the city.
What a heartbreaking site.
Voltron wrote weary women,
frightened girls,
trudging with children and bedding and small packages of clothes.
If only someone had time to write the story of each refugee who came in.
She thought,
especially the stories of the girls who had black and their faces and cut their
hair,
has she accommodated the stream of wild eyed women?
She heard stories of Japanese raping girls as young as 12 and women is elderly a
60 or raping pregnant women at Bayonet Point?
Yeah.
And
yeah,
the
sick and deprived and disgusting in horrific stories go on and on and on.
And the brutality page after page after page of diary entries and quotes and
witness accounts
and then pictures,
there's pictures in the book.
Okay.
The pictures of severed heads and Chinese bound to polls being bayoneted to
death and pictures of others being beheaded in pictures of giant pits filled
with bodies and images of hundreds and hundreds of bodies and entangles masses
on the banks of the gangs.
He River.
It's
okay.
It's,
it's too much for the mind to comprehend.
It really is.
It's almost too much to understand.
And so what we do
is we package it all up,
right.
And we give it a name,
a massacre.
Okay.
Or an atrocity.
And I'm sure you could tell,
I mean,
even as I'm sitting here reading this,
I'm gone,
I'm just numb.
But we
BAFTA remembered that every one of those people
tortured,
raped,
and he killed.
Was a person,
a person like your brother or like your sister or like your mom or like your
dad.
Okay.
Or a person like your son or your daughter.
A person
like you
and maybe you can get ahold of that.
But what's in some ways even harder to grasp is the Japanese soldiers
the day where people,
and yes,
they were certainly monsters,
vial
and despicable and completely devoid of feelings,
but even so,
even though they were were monsters,
they were human monsters
and they too had mothers and fathers and sons and daughters.
And yet they did this.
And the fact that what happened at Nan king was so brutal.
And so beyond comparison with anything that ever happened.
Yeah,
it was one of the things that almost caused it to be forgotten
and that that supreme level of brutality lasted about six weeks.
And eventually that morphed into an occupation of Nan king by the Japanese.
And they ruled with an iron fist of course.
And they stole and they plundered a navy abused locals and they continued to,
to rape,
which they actually institutional institutionalized and,
and eventually became,
okay,
you've heard the term comfort women
and they gave out opium freely to unsaved people.
Just like happens in this day and age,
people become slaves to drugs.
And it stayed in that occupied state for,
yeah,
about eight years until finally,
almost as quickly as it began.
It ended
going back to the book.
The end of Nan kings or deal came in the last game at last in the summer of 1945
on August 6th,
1945 the United States dropped an untested uranium bomb on Hiroshima Japan's
eighth largest city killing 100,000 of its 245 people,
245,000 people on the first day
when the Japanese surrender was not forthcoming,
the Americans dropped on August 9th a second plutonium type bomb on the Japanese
city of Nagasaki.
Okay.
Less than a week later on August 14th the Japanese made the final decision to
surrender.
The Japanese remained in the former capitol of China until the day of the
Then quickly left the city I witnesses reported that Japanese soldier could be
seen drinking heavily or weeping in the streets.
Some heard rumors of unarmed Japanese men being forced to kneel by the side of
the road to be beaten by local residents.
Retaliation against the Japanese garrison appears to be to have been limited.
However,
because many residents he had at home during this chaotic time too fearful to
even celebrate the news of a Japanese defeat,
the evacuation was swift and there was no mass persecution or imprisonment of
Japanese soldiers.
One Nan king resident recalls that she stayed in her house for weeks after the
Japanese surrendered and when she reemerged they were gone.
And so it was over
and there were work,
some,
some level of war crime trials and there were some executions.
Yeah,
mainly of the highest profile officer's Prince Osaka who had given that order to
kill all captives.
He avoided prosecution.
The scale of the massacre was downplayed.
And the reason that,
there's a bunch of reasons of why the scale of the rape of Nan king got
downplayed.
One of them being at the now Chinese communist state was actually trying to
build relationships with post war Japan.
So the massacre was quietly buried in and now you had the Chinese people were
now in a communist state and there wasn't much speaking out to do.
Okay.
And the Japanese downplayed the horrors
as saying it was a,
you know,
just another incident of war.
And some Japanese officials were quoted as saying,
it's a story made up by the Chinese.
It's tarnish the image of Japan.
But it was a lie.
Okay.
And they said things like,
I think the Nan king massacres ally,
the women that were raped were labeled as comfort women and licensed
prostitutes.
And many Japanese officials say that what happened in Nan king was just a part
of war.
And there's a really clear example of downplaying not only the rape of Nan king,
but of the war in general.
And they put this,
some of this in the book,
they're talking about the,
the Japanese education system.
Here we go back to the book.
The Japanese,
the entire Japanese education system suffers from selective amnesia for not
until 1994 where Japanese school children taught that here he knows army was
responsible for the deaths of at least 20 million allied soldiers and Asian
civilians during World War II.
In the net.
In the early 1990s a newspaper article quoted a Japanese high school teacher who
claimed that his students were surprised to learn that Japan had been at war
with the United States.
The first thing they wanted to know was who had one.
In 1997 and 1977 the ministry of Education reduced a section on World War II
within a standard history book of several hundred pages to only six pages,
which consisted mainly of pictures of American firebombing of Tokyo,
a picture of the ruins of Hiroshima and Itali of Japan's war dead.
Okay.
The texts neglected dimension,
the casualties on the other side,
Japanese war atrocities or the forced evacuations of Chinese and Korean
prisoners to labor camps in Japan.
Much of the censorship might've gone on challenged had it not been for the
efforts of one brave crusader.
In 1965 the Japanese historian and Nigga Suburu sued the Japanese government.
This lawsuit was the beginning of a legal battle that would span three decades
and gain the backing of thousands of sympathetic Japanese followers.
The ministry interfered with a Neg as attempts to document the Nan king massacre
for school children.
For example,
in His textbook manuscript,
a Nega wrote,
he wrote this quote immediately after the occupation of Nan King,
the Japanese army killed numerous Chinese soldiers and citizens.
This incident became known as the as the Nan king massacre.
Now when when his book got checked by the examiner,
the examiner commented,
quote,
readers might interpret this description has meeting meaning that the Japanese
army unilaterally massacred Chinese immediately after the occupation.
This passage should be revised that it is not interpreted in such a way
and here's what the passage eventually got changed to while battling the fierce
resistance of the Chinese armed forces,
the Japanese occupied Nan king and killed numerous Chinese soldiers and
civilians.
This incident came to be known as the Nan King massacre,
that a statement and quote that a statement might have been satisfied.
That statement might have satisfied textbook sensors as a compromise between a
niggas argument and the ministry's position on the massacre.
Unfortunately,
the statement is simply not true because it implies that the massacre occurred
in the heat of battle.
Continuing on.
The examiner demanded that a nega delete his description of the rape itself,
claiming that the violation of women is something that has happened on every
battlefield in every era of human history.
This is not an issue that needs to be taken up with respect to the Japanese army
in particular.
Okay.
Even the word aggression was deemed taboo.
Aggression.
The sensors wrote is a term that contains negative ethical connotations.
Okay.
And that spirit that you can see very clearly,
that spirit of denial,
it carried on,
which is why when this book came out,
this book,
the rape of Nanking when it came out,
there was still Japanese nationalists that were staunchly against it,
but Iris Chang who researched intently and wrote with passion,
she gave it all right does.
She was a daughter of Chinese American immigrants and her parents by the way had
connections to Nan King and an escape there
and both her parents had made it to America and become college professors.
And Iris was
compelled to tell this story.
But like I said in the beginning,
she was so close to this story that it took a toll of its own.
And she was a writer,
obviously.
She got her bachelor's degree in journalism and eventually a master's in writing
from Johns Hopkins University.
And
there's actually a book that's written about Iris.
And then the book is written by Iris,
his mother,
whose name is Dr Ying Ying Chiang.
And the book is called the woman who could not forget.
And I'm going to bring you through some portions of this book.
So this book,
again,
this is about Iris Chang and it's written
by her mother.
How she got
yeah,
is now she decided she was gonna write about this.
Here we go,
quote.
Although Iris talked to us about her many book ideas for her next book while she
was writing our first book,
her decision to write the rape of Nan king came all of a sudden in December,
1994 as iris told us and as described in the book,
she made her mind to write about this most atrocious chapter of history when she
was attending a conference in California on December 13th,
1994 at the conference,
there was a photo exhibition of the war of the war crimes committed in China in
the 1930s taken when the Japanese army invaded Chinese territory.
Iris wrote in her book,
though I had heard so much about the Nan king massacre as a child,
nothing prepared me for these pictures.
Stark black and white images of decapitated heads,
Belize,
ripped open a nude women forced by their rapists into various pornographic
poses.
Their faces contort it into unforgettable expressions of agony and shame and she
continued in a single blinding moment.
I recognized that fragility of not just life,
but the human experience itself.
Okay.
Later.
She told us in a telephone update that she simply must write about the rape of
Nanking for next book.
It was a moral obligation and it would be justice for the victims as well.
In 1998 after the rape of Nan king had been published,
one Japanese reporter interviewed Iris and asked her,
why did you decide to write this book?
Irish replied,
when I was a little girl,
my parents shocked me with the story of the rape of Nan King.
They told me that the Japanese imperial army massacred thousands of civilians in
the capital of China and butchered even small children.
This left a powerful impression on me and I went to local libraries to learn
more details,
but I couldn't find a shred of information on the subject.
There was nothing in my local school libraries or public city libraries or in my
world history textbooks.
Still worse.
My teachers were completely ignorant of this event.
Okay.
The event remained a question mark in my mind for years until I saw an exhibit a
for photographs on the subject in 1994 the horror of those photographs inspired
me to write the book.
Okay.
So that's how I
got involved in writing the book and as a writer,
luckily she was also a prolific letter writer and I'm going to quote a bunch of
her letters because her mother saved a bunch of her letters.
And here is one that Kinda describes,
I think it's a good insight into what her personality was like when she was
actually writing the book.
This was a letter to her mom about what she was doing on a day to day basis as
she's writing this book.
And this was her second
book.
She,
so she'd already written one book.
It had done okay,
but this one was her,
you know,
our current project and here's what she said about it.
On a typical day,
I would rise between seven and 8:00 AM and take the bus to silver spring metro
station.
Fortunately,
there was a bus stop directly across from Lee's house.
The trip to the national archives took about 45 minutes on public transportation
and the building was opened by 8:45 AM I spent my mornings in the military
reference branch of the archives on the 13th floor looking through finding aids
and filling out cards to request boxes from different collections of papers.
Dozens of boxes would be pulled from the shelves,
placed on carts and made available to me in the second floor reading room,
which stayed open until 9:00 PM on Tuesdays,
Thursdays,
and Fridays.
I was usually there in the afternoons and evenings scanning documents,
tagging the ones that pertained to the Nanking massacre and xeroxing them as
quickly as possible.
So she's digging deep into this book,
doing massive amount of research and you know,
research back then was infinitely harder than it is now because we have the
Internet now.
As she began,
she,
she assembled all this information and she was starting to starting to speak
about it,
starting to write some articles about it before the book came out.
And she was interviewed by the San Jose Mercury News,
which was a big newspaper up in the South Bay area of,
you know,
South Bay San Francisco.
And uh,
she,
when she got done with that interview,
she started getting a little bit of recognition.
So here's a letter to her mom.
Dear mom,
here's the latest exciting news.
I shall be the master of ceremonies for what I believe will be the biggest rape
of Nanking conference ever.
The event will take place at Stanford University during the first weekend of
December.
Hundreds of people for more than 50 activist organizations all over the globe
will be there as well as representatives from all major news media organizations
of California,
China and Japan.
The goal of the three day affairs to discuss legal strategy.
How can we see,
seek reparations for the victims through international law and UN resolutions?
How can we gather evidence of atrocity for,
of atrocities,
for lawsuits?
What methods should we use to force the Japanese to accept responsibility for
its past misdeeds?
So she's in the game.
She's getting after it.
She starting to get some leadership positions in here and starting to get some
recognition now as she's continued to work.
Here's another letter to her mom.
Dear mom,
thank you for your inspirational email.
I've been working on my book all week and feel more confident about my material.
The sections of the book are so short that I organize each chapter as I would
have speech.
Thinking of the chapters as speeches forces me to distill each idea into a tiny
hard gem.
Lately I've been reading so many of the world's classic speeches for
inspiration.
They are breathtaking in their power and so much more pungent than pros in the
evenings.
When I read the speeches of Napoleon or Clarence Darrow or Winston Churchill,
I feel engaged in the actual conversation with them.
Words are the only way to preserve the essence of a soul.
What excites me about speeches is that even after the speakers are dead and
buried,
their spirit lives on.
To me.
This is true religion,
the best form of life after death.
This is the first time I've ever devoted much attention to speeches.
My previous reading had only consisted mainly of essays,
plays,
novels and poetry,
Love Iris,
so it's pretty cool that you,
first of all,
I love that letter because she's recognizing the power of speech and she's,
she's realizing that what she's doing as an author is that's,
that's her,
that's her mark that she's going to leave on the world and it's very interesting
that yinging Chang is also an academic.
She's a,
you know,
obviously a really smart person and they're able to have these sort of
intellectual conversations and in letters and they're all a really good insight
into what iris is mind,
what was going through irises mind as she did this.
Now the book comes out,
there's,
it doesn't like jump out of the gates,
but as it comes out there's a little bit of controversy about it.
And so there started to be some articles about it and some interviews and she's
getting some interviews and the book starts to get some good traction
back to the book.
On January 14th she flew to Washington for a TV interview with PBS
at the San Francisco Airport.
She left a telephone message for us and said that she'd gotten a call from her
publisher and that her book was number 15 on the New York Times bestsellers
list.
Her voice told us she was weeping.
I'm sure they were tears of Joy Shao Jin,
which is the dad and I were jubilant.
We could not contain our excitement for many days and the next phone call we
said,
Iris,
you've made it.
So Book Hits The New York Times bestseller.
That's the game changer for Iris.
Back to the book on Eye.
On January 28th Irish called us with excitement and said that Laurel Cook,
her publicist and Jack Mckeown,
the CEO had called her in the afternoon to tell her that her book was up to
number 11 on the New York Times list,
her highest spot yet only two weeks after first making the list when they
called,
she could hear wild cheering,
whistling and clapping in the background.
She was overjoyed.
So it's like the big,
the big thing and
as a writer is to make the New York Times list and,
and,
and her parents understand that too because they're academics and you know,
they're,
they're super stoked for IRS.
Now with the success starts to come,
some stress and that starts to reveal itself.
Here's another letter that she wrote.
Dear mom,
I'm sorry that I sounded so rushed when you called me at Miriam's home.
Sometimes I wonder if I've offended a lot of old friends in the last few months
by not returning emails,
phone calls and letters perhaps many people believe I've been corrupted already.
It's true that I've neglected my loved ones for the last few months.
I feel ashamed that I haven't yet brought,
bought you a mother's Day gift or even a card only.
This note that I am hastily writing from my laptop computer perched up on a bed
and Diana sacraments house.
How I wish you could have been there during the woman of the year ceremony.
I told you,
I told the audience how you inspired me over the years,
how you served as my first role model.
He's got another big award,
a woman of the year.
Right.
Please forgive me.
I love you dearly,
even though I haven't found the time to talk to you in the last few weeks,
and in a few weeks we'll all be reunited and the book tour,
we'll finally be over.
I feel like a soldier returning from a six month war.
Love Iris.
So she's a person that feels guilt,
you know,
and,
and the idea that she hasn't been returned and emails and phone calls and she
feels bad about it.
And then I found this interesting,
perhaps many people believe I've been corrupted already.
Oh,
so you made it big time and now you're blowing me off.
She's feeling that pressure too.
Back to the book.
When Iris is book became an international bestseller,
she reached the status.
Most writers can only dream of it.
She became a celebrity.
Okay.
But she also paid a price for it in February,
1998 after a long book tour,
she had already told us that once she came home,
she did not want to go out anymore.
All she wanted to do was stay home with Brett.
That was her husband.
She'd been married now and have a good sleep.
After several weeks of continuous book signings,
public speeches,
and traveling,
she said her life was nonstop blur of airport,
Lecture Hall,
Hotel,
airport,
Lecture Hall Hotel.
The responses to her speeches were overwhelming.
Wherever she went,
people besieged her after every speech.
When she came home,
she never really came down with a cold or a flu,
only recover in time for the next book tour.
She was physically exhausted.
Not only that,
but during the book signings,
many old Asian people came up to her Chinese,
Korean,
Filipino,
Singaporean,
Indian.
They poured their personal stories
of suffering during World War Two and in Asia to her,
some of them wept and thanked her for profusely for writing such a book.
They said,
it's so frustrating to see that Japan to this day hasn't formally acknowledged
their war crimes.
They exclaimed,
it's about time I ever said all of that.
On the one hand,
she felt rewarded that she was sought out and greatly respected by many people,
but on the other hand,
he was mentally and emotionally drained.
After hearing those stories on June 29th,
1998 Irish wrote,
dear mom,
I arrived safely in New York today after giving a well received speech in
Baltimore to the women doctors.
Actually it was very depressing during the Q and a.
A Pakistani doctor told the audience about the atrocities against Bengali women
in 1971 a Filipino doctor described how she escaped the rape of Manila when she
was 12 and an Indian doctor had discussed the Indian tradition of Sooty,
which is the burning of widows alive.
Others talked about the interaction,
international sex slave industry,
the trafficking of women and children,
female genital mutilation in Africa.
You get the idea.
It seemed there were endless gruesome stories that people were eager to share
with her
on top of her busy schedule of book tours outside.
People might not realize that besides her traveling signings in books and
speeches,
she was constantly bombarded with additional email request from news reporters
for written interviews.
Sometimes there were 10 or 15 written questions for her to answers so the
reporters could write a news article and profile.
I risked to still could find time to answer those questions accordingly.
So she's just,
uh,
she's just to go get her right.
She's not stopping regardless of what's happening.
And now as this book is gained,
all this popularity,
now she's starting to get some attacks as well from,
like I said,
from the Japanese nationalists that are saying,
Oh,
this didn't happen.
You're,
you're glorifying it or you're making it sound like worse than it was.
And here's the letter that you wrote.
Dear mom,
tonight I read an article about John Stomberg Steinbeck's life in the,
in the Los Gatos mountain area and learn that the reception of the Grapes of
Wrath mirrored that of the rape of Nan King in a letter to a friend.
Steinbeck wrote the vilification of me out here from the large landowners and
bankers is pretty bad.
The latest rumor started by them that the Okies hate me for lying about them.
So I'm frightened at the rolling might have this thing.
It is completely out of hand.
I mean,
the kind of hysteria about the book is growing that is not healthy love Iris.
So she feels the same way that she's starting to.
This book is almost becoming
more powerful than she,
you know,
more,
more than she can control.
And here's another,
another letter that she wrote
a few nights ago.
I leafed through Richard Rhodes autobiography,
a hole in the world after our lunch together.
As you know,
Rhodes was starved,
beaten,
and psychologically abused as a child by his step mother.
His mother had committed suicide by shooting herself and his father degenerated
into an alcoholic,
leaving him virtually incapable of protecting his family.
Every time I reread this book,
I'm convinced that Richard Rhodes is lucky to be alive.
He was a genuine victim,
but even his experience pales in comparison to the stories of abandoned children
in the PRC orphanages.
That's People's Republic of China.
I don't even want to get into that right now.
Delving into history into other people's stories,
places,
all our problems into perspective time and again,
we have to remind ourselves how extraordinarily lucky we are.
Much love Iris.
Clearly.
That's something that I talk about on a regular basis.
You look at the suffering that other people go through and it reminds you of how
lucky we are not to be in those situations,
but it seemed like I was was having a hard time maintaining that positive
outlook and she's keeps getting dragged down into the darkness.
Back to the book,
hearing that peanuts cartoonists,
Charles Schultz had died.
Iris was quite sentimental and wrote me a letter and here's the letter quote.
Dear mom,
I have a favorite ask you.
Can you save the last peanuts comic strip that appeared yesterday and mail it to
me?
I'm still reeling from the news of Charles Schulz is death.
It's the end of an era.
I still remember all the hours I spent reading peanuts books as a child.
Do you recall the time we went together to a garage sale and champagne and you
brought me my first snoopy cartoon book,
a used paper back already yellow with age.
That's when I first fell in love with the peanuts comic strip.
You and dad grew up with a PM peanuts cartoon as well in Chinese new pit
newspapers and Taiwan making both of you part of the peanuts era as well.
Years later in Santa Barbara,
I met Charles Soldier in person at the SB writer's conference during his
lecture.
However,
I was surprised by his demeanor,
which was bitter,
gloomy and depressed,
almost nasty.
After his lecture,
I stood in a long line waiting for Schultz to autograph a copy of his book.
When I finally stood in front of him,
I asked Schulte if I could write a profile about him for the New Yorker or some
other major match magazine.
Why is young person like
you interested in an old man like me was his response?
At the time,
I thought he was being sarcastic,
but later I learned that Schultz like Charlie Brown is a terribly insecure
person,
fundamentally convinced of his own unworthiness.
That was the last time I ever spoke.
I ever saw Schultz,
but last year I had one more opportunity to see him.
To make a long story short,
I didn't have time to make the long two hour drive to Santa Rosa and I figured I
would see Schultes at the next Santa Barbara's writer's conference.
I never expected that Schultes would pass away.
Only a few months later.
Okay.
Do you think Charles Schultz committed suicide?
Don't you find it odd that he died the night before his final strip ran in the
Sunday newspaper has,
you know,
peanuts ran from 1950 to 2000 a perfect 50 years and he died right when the
strip ended,
but life is seldom as neat and tidy as a cartoon box.
It's almost as if he timed his dramatic exit from this world achieving his final
deadline.
Love Iris,
continue going.
It seems like Iris could not get the death of Charles shirts shorts off her mind
the next day.
She wrote to me again about him,
dear mom,
I think it was Charles Salts is pessimism as well as the ability to understand
human failure,
insecurity,
heartbreak that made millions love peanuts.
You're absolutely right.
Schultes had no reason whatsoever to be depressed after achieving wealth and
fame at such an early age.
But depression is not rational.
Perhaps he did have a mental problem or some chemically induced condition,
but whatever it was,
it prevented him from losing touch with the underdogs of the world.
Okay.
It's strange,
but I still feel a void in my heart after Schulze his death,
even though I never knew him and didn't particularly like him after our meeting
in person,
it made me wonder,
what is the secret to Shults is magic appeal?
The answer I believe is simple.
Schultes understands a heart of a loser.
He capture those moments in life when we feel utterly unload,
unloved,
unwanted,
and alone all of us,
no matter how successful have felt like losers at some point in life.
Yeah,
Love Iris.
So you're starting to see there's a,
there's a
an indication,
right?
There's an indication.
She's sort of seeing things like depression.
You other people,
regardless of,
you know,
how successful they are.
And at this point,
you know,
she's in New York Times bestseller and woman of the year,
all this other stuff.
So she's successful and yet she's recognizing how that doesn't really mean
anything and you can still be depressed.
After 11th
2001 she wrote this,
Oh,
a few days after it,
she wrote this again to her mom and dad.
In this case,
quote,
events are unfolding faster than I can react to them.
First the WTC and Pentagon tragedies.
Then the Japanese prime ministers,
unexpected apology to the comfort women and now a major court victory of a
former Korean slave labor against the Japanese corporation.
This week I tried to work on my book and recover from General Exhaustion and a
mild case of the flu,
but I have to admit it's hard to stay focused.
I plan to do nothing more than right and exercise and rest for the next few
weeks.
Love Iris.
So she's now working on her next book.
Still working hard,
probably working too hard,
not focusing enough.
And her mom now she's got a kid as well and we know that adding a kid into the
mix doesn't make things,
you know,
that doesn't give you more free time.
We can promise you that.
And she's married now.
She has a son and
yeah,
her mom actually started like putting some pressure on him.
He said,
hey,
you know,
you got a kid now you got to spend,
maybe you're going a little overboard with the work.
Hmm.
Back to the book on October 3rd,
2003 and an email,
I asked iris whether she was putting too much emphasis on her career,
placing your career before her family.
She replied,
that is not true.
It's just that I believe that I have some power to shape my destiny and I want
Christopher t.
That's the sun.
I want Christopher to have his mother a strong to have in his mother a strong
role model.
A person who is his own individual,
impervious to the whims of others.
I cannot teach Christopher to be an intellectual and a socially responsible
person unless I demonstrate to him through my actions that I myself am such a
person.
I want to teach Christopher,
that it is far better to be long
to the critical minority than the unquestioning majority.
I want to teach him the ability to think independently,
to evaluate ideas and information on his own without the official sanction of
the authorities and if possible,
to create these qualities are not universally popular in our society.
My tendency to stand alone,
apart from the crowd has caused me a great pain and suffering throughout my
life,
but in the end I am stronger and better person because of it.
Now
she's continued all and she's continuing to just kind of grind and grind and
grind and there's an incident.
Okay,
she's gone on a trip to Louisville,
Kentucky and things start going sideways.
Back to the book.
That night we went to sleep and assume that iris would be all right,
but about 2:00 AM California time in the early morning of Friday,
August 13th we are awakened by a phone call.
I picked up the phone and it was iris.
Her voice was shaking and she told me she'd seen some frightening pictures on
the TV in her hotel room,
iris and I then had a conversation about this.
Apparently she could not fall asleep,
so she turned on the TV.
I asked her what kind of pictures were on the TV screen.
She said it showed some horrible atrocities and ugly images of children torn
apart by wars.
Okay.
She said that the TV was showing something similar to scenes from hell like an
automatic and world war three
she had turned off their TV,
waited a while,
and then turn it on again to find the ugly images had disappeared.
I responded that maybe the TV had been showing a war movie.
It's very possible.
I said that during the wee hours of the night,
TV stations would show such a genre of horror films.
Then Iris told me she did not feel things had been quite right.
From the very moment she'd arrived at the hotel,
the clerk at the front desk looks suspicious to her and spoke to a person who
later kept looking at the window of her room.
While Iris was still talking with me on the phone,
she told me that she could still see that person standing outside on the lawn in
front,
not far from her room.
He looked at her window and as she peered through her curtain,
she told me she spoke to her room was wired and that what she had seen on TV was
real and intentionally show to threaten her.
So she's getting paranoid.
He's paranoid that Japanese nationalists are coming after her.
She's had is starting to affect her mind.
Back to the book,
it was past 5:00 AM in Kentucky.
I asked her had she gotten any sleep at all.
She said she couldn't fall asleep and she was exhausted and had a terrible
headache.
She was sick.
I could tell she had to be ill because she had not been able to sleep for three
or four days prior to the trip.
Okay.
She also had not eaten,
nor has she drunk any liquid for some time.
She said she'd ordered some takeout dinner that was delivered to her room,
but she did not have any appetite and hadn't eaten anything.
She didn't want to drink anything either afraid that someone might poison her.
I knew that under severe sleep deprivation people could have delusions,
so her parents decide they're gonna,
they're gonna fly while she has a breakdown and they get a call saying,
hey,
something happened at Iris.
You need to get out here.
They fly out to Louisville.
As soon as they get to Louisville,
they go to the hospital.
When she gets to,
when they get to the hospital,
she,
they,
they go to find her and she's in the psychiatric unit and they,
she was sent to the psychiatric unit because they hadn't found anything wrong
with her physically,
which you know,
would include in my opinion.
And that includes like,
hey,
she's not dehydrated.
She's not starving.
She's got some psychiatric issues.
So back to the book in the evening,
the doctor finally came in and met with us.
He briefed us on iris has conditioned in front of all of us.
He believed iris.
It experienced a so called a brief reactive psychosis due to stress conditions
such as lack of sleep and food.
He added that her condition could also be a possible onset of bipolar disorder
and recommended that I receive a doctor for followup.
After her return home,
he gave us a reference.
He also prescribed an antipsychotic drug,
drug,
Risperdal,
two milligrams a day for Iris to take for at least a year.
And then they,
they
getting the cab and as she'd get in the cab,
she's kind of like making statements and saying strange things about what she
sees.
Billboards,
she's making strange comments about them.
And finally they landed San Jose airport and go back to the book we called
Michael and that's the,
that's uh,
the sun or irises brother.
We called Michael to come pick us up while we're waiting for Michael.
I read said that she felt dizzy and had a headache.
She told me that things seem distorted there,
her and that the expressions of people around her were strange.
At that time.
We did not know how powerful psychiatric drugs were and thought that iris,
his behavior was strange.
I later realized that while in the hospital,
Irish had been given heavy doses of risperdol and a tranquilizer to calm her
down.
The side effects of psychiatric drugs could be severe.
That explained why she felt dizzy and had a headache and distortion of a visual
perception.
So she's now on these drugs.
She's,
she's taking the,
the risk beer drawl,
two milligrams a day,
the medicines making her super sleepy and once they're back in the bay area,
the mom,
uh,
yinging starts looking for,
you know,
a board certified psychiatrist to bring her to and she ends up with this guy
that they called doctor B back to the book at Iris,
who is now seeing Dr be once a week.
And she persuaded him to reduce her dose shoots,
dosage of risk per girl risperdol by half from one milligram or from to one
milligram,
from,
from two down to one.
From the very beginning,
iris did not like to take any drugs and she kept trying to reduce the dosage or
stop it entirely.
The rest of the family was hoping that with the Risperdol,
iris would be less depressed,
but to no avail.
There was no difference.
So interestingly,
IRS is saying,
hey,
I don't want to take this drug.
You know,
I want to get off of it.
And they're all saying,
look,
just keep taking it.
And
eventually he just,
he prescribes her with another drug,
which is called amplify.
And as soon as,
or back to the book,
as soon as Irish took the amplify milligrams that she became excessively sleepy,
she could sleep for 12 hours or more straight.
So now she's sleeping,
I mean 12 hours a day,
bad.
And back to the book,
I always felt that her illness and inability to take care of Christopher was a
burden to everyone.
Something she hated.
I could see that she was very sad and felt helpless.
So this continues on.
And finally they go back to a meeting with doctor B.
Doctor,
be stunned us all with what he said next in a very serious tone.
He said he thought iris condition was very grave and he suggested that iris
check into a recovery facility.
He said that the facility was in Saulsalito near the beach.
It was quite ideal for mental patients to recuperate.
As soon as iris heard this,
she immediately showed her disapproval.
I could understand her suspicion of any facility designed for so called mental
patients.
She had learned many historical instances of government persecution of political
dissidence.
One way was to put those dissidents into mental institutions and abused them,
sometimes leading to death.
I did not blame her for her suspicions.
She was already suspecting that evil forces were at work against her for what
she had written and done in the name of justice Dr B,
she told Dr [inaudible] that she did not think her mental state was that bad and
that she didn't need to go to a recovery facility,
so they start looking for someone else to take her to besides doctor B and now
she gets prescribed another drug which is called Selectsa and so she's on Alexa
and she's on an apple fi and back to the book at this time,
or sorry,
Abilify.
At this time,
Iris was already experiencing the strong side effects of Abilify,
most obvious where her lack of energy and the fact that she was drowsy all the
time.
In addition,
when she woke up from her daily naps,
she complained that her shoulders and leg joints were sore,
which were new symptoms that she thought likely to have been caused by the drug.
I was worried about the side effects of Abilify and voiced my concern to doctor
B.
He said the dosage was the lowest possible and that the side effects would
gradually disappear.
In retrospect,
it appears to us that Abilify had a big impact on irises,
mental state.
It was a turning point in her condition became worse after she started taking
the Abilify and late and then later worsened and even more with Selectsa.
So now a another incident takes place.
She kind of disappears for a little bit.
No one really knows where she is.
They call the cops to find out.
Eventually she calls back and she says,
Hey,
look,
I was out.
I was tired.
I checked into a hotel to get some sleep.
That's the story she tells and she's,
her mom says she sounds guilty as she's trying to tell this story.
And then a few days later they,
they find the some sleeping pills and a bottle of vodka and they're kind of
realized that she was,
do you know,
thinking about committing suicide?
But you know,
her mom says she probably just went into a room to do that and fell asleep when
she woke up.
I guess she changed her mind and you know,
back to the book here on the drugs that she was taken.
We now know that Abilify website warns that the drug can affect your judgment
thinking or motor skills as well as the side effects of increasing risk of
suicide,
drowsiness,
anxiety and muscle stiffness.
And the Selectsa wa website warns about suicide,
anxiety
and self destructive or aggressive impulses.
So these drugs that you take for these problems have side effects that sound,
you know,
worse than what the problem is.
Then she goes on to say that that the first attempted suicide that she made,
so this,
this attempt was a when she was,
when she was on 10 milligrams of Abilify and the other thing that that mentions
in these about these drugs is that when you change prescription,
when you change doses or you go on or off of them,
that's when you're most vulnerable.
And so that suicide attempt was inline with one of those changes.
So they go back to now that with another doctor doc who they called Doctor See,
going back to the book I read,
stopped taking selects on October 7th after the support group meeting,
she told Dr [inaudible] on the phone that she would discontinue seeing him if he
insisted on are taking the med medicine as a compromise.
Doctor C persuaded her to continue seeing him and then he would decide whether
she could gradually decrease the dosage of Risperdol,
which she was still on.
All of us told Iris that both the medication and the psychotherapy sessions were
needed for rapid recovery.
If she didn't want to take the medication,
then at least she should have.
She should have psychotherapy sessions with the doctor.
She agreed to continue seeing Dr. See,
looking back at what ended up happening,
it was so ironic.
I risk was the one who did not want to take the medication,
whereas the rest of the family believed in doctors and thought the medication
would help her.
Continuing on the morning of Thursday,
October 21st when I went to see her,
she was very unhappy and complained that I was following her too closely.
I found she had not eaten well the night before,
so I suggested going out for lunch.
We drove to nearby restaurant in the parking lot.
When she stopped the car,
she sat there and told me without any expression that she wanted to cry but had
no tears.
Her face was greenish and in a horrible,
depressed state at this time.
She had already mentioned that she did not want to live anymore.
I also noticed that her arm and leg movements and facial expressions were rigid
and it seemed even worse that she wanted to cry but had no tears
back then.
I did not suspect that all of these symptoms could be the serious side effects
of the medications.
Iris began to feel hopeless.
I later realized she wanted to carry out her plan and she did not want us to
find out in the last week of her life.
She prohibited me from visiting her.
She would not even want me to call her and did not return my calls or my emails.
In that final week,
Shao Jin and I took a walk ourselves to ease our worries.
I went to a Palo Alto support group on Wednesday,
November 3rd Shao Jin and I went to another support group in San Jose.
On Friday,
November 5th we tried to gather information on how to deal with depression and
loved ones who are possibly suicidal
for all this time.
She was actively planning her final exit.
While we tried to find a way to rescue her,
we raced against her and we did not realize that she would carry out her plan so
quickly.
One week later on November 9th she was gone.
Yeah,
and here is the note that was found
next to irises computer.
Dear Brett,
mom,
Dad,
and Mike for the last few weeks,
I've been struggling with my decision as to whether I should live or die.
As I mentioned to Brett,
when you believe you have a future,
you think of terms of generations and years.
When you do not,
you live just by the day you live,
not just by the day,
but by the minute.
You don't want someone who will live out the rest of her days as a mere shell of
her former self.
I had considered running away,
but I will never be able to escape from myself and my thoughts.
I am doing this because I am too weak to withstand the years of pain and agony
ahead.
Each breath is becoming difficult for me to take.
The anxiety can be compared to drowning in an open sea.
I know that my actions will transfer some of this pain to others.
Indeed,
those who love me the most,
please forgive me.
Forgive me because I can not forgive myself.
Love
Iris.
When irises mom closes out the book saying it was an untimely death.
Yeah.
Over the years.
Iris had always commented that life was too short for her to finish the thing
she wanted to accomplish.
She said many times that she wanted to write more books to make films and record
more oral histories.
It was so painful to realize that many of her dreams were not fulfilled,
yet.
It is not how she died,
but rather how she lived.
That will be her legacy.
Whenever I think of Iris,
the memories of a loving daughter and a beautiful soul will always remain with
me.
In her short 36 years,
she had inspired many,
many people in the world with her noble spirit,
her passion,
dedication,
sincerity,
and determination
in preserving historical truth and pursuing justice for the voiceless victims.
Iris was a woman whose heartbeat passionately for those who suffered.
She was a woman who could not forget,
she could not forget their agony and she refused to let their stories go.
Untold,
iris is life.
We're short but brilliant
like a splendid rainbow across the sky.
One that the goddess she was named after would be proud of
iris is rainbow was magnificent,
vanishing quickly.
Okay,
cool.
A rainbow vanishing quickly.
And I guess that that is what we all are
purine bow vanishing quickly.
But before we vanish,
I say
shine,
all that darkness in the world.
Be the light,
be the color,
be the good and the strong and the brightness that drives away the dark.
We have.
But one chance here,
one chance,
one opportunity to stretch across the sky and shine
value that
value,
that value life
[inaudible] know
that the light will spread
and good will prevail.
It will prevail over evil.
So long
as we stand up,
stand up
against all that wickedness in the world,
we stand up,
okay.
Gunshot.
And I think that's all I've got for tonight.
Echo,
why don't you go ahead and take the mic for a minute there
for while I decompress over on this side.
Sure.
I was,
uh,
let's talk,
talking with Greg Train yesterday
and you can complain about something where you can embrace,
this is one of the big things that kind of learned you.
And this
is like when you look at your own situation compared to other past situations
that are way worse,
right?
So one you start with,
okay,
your,
your situation isn't that bad.
That's what you start with.
Then you go on to,
okay my situation,
these are small,
teeny tiny talent challenges that all you have to do is approach them in this
way of like embracing it.
You know how like,
um,
like anytime,
okay,
anytime you're feeling frustrated about your situation or whatever.
Right.
And it really impersonal when you put it in perspective,
these are small challenges that you just got to overcome.
You take it on as it's like,
yeah you want to put more work on my plate at work cause I couldn't feel it
because I can handle it and I'll do it the best and watch me work.
You know?
That is good.
And an interesting w you know
when,
when we had Tim Ferriss on here and when I did Tim Ferriss interview the first
time I was on his podcast and he,
it's the thing that I talked about when he came on here.
Like I,
he asked the question sort of saying,
hey,
how close to you get to the darkness before it consumes you?
And I've talked about before,
uh,
you know,
if you stare into the soul of a monster,
you have to be careful because you might become a monster.
And so I,
I mean,
I,
I think yeah,
there's the drugs that she got put on obviously played a role,
but she got in this world where all she saw was the bad.
Yeah.
And I think that to Tim Ferriss,
his point where he was saying to me like,
hey,
how often should I get close to the darkness?
You know,
how often should I look at that?
And you know,
my response was,
hey,
you,
in order to know the light,
you got to know the darkness,
but you can absolutely go too far in that direction.
And you can say to yourself,
wow,
the world is evil and everyone's evil.
And underneath the surface everyone could turn it into this imperial Japanese
soldier and commit these atrocities.
And that is what you absolutely.
And I would say be careful.
I don't know if that's the right word.
I guess it is the right word.
Be careful.
But to me,
which you have to do is you,
you have to balance it.
And to me,
as an American,
as a band,
there's so much good,
right?
I think that people generally get get jaded to all the good that's out there.
And that's why I say,
Hey,
you know what?
Look over here at the darkness,
but for someone that's stuck in a horrible place,
in a horrible situation in life,
that's those.
Those folks got to look out and say,
wait a second,
there's not,
there's so much good out there.
You know,
if you can take it like that's clearly,
I mean,
you look at,
look at Iris Chang.
I mean,
she is smart and successful and beautiful and well liked and had a,
she came up with an amazing family.
Her parents were adored her,
right?
She had every thing in her life was good,
And she lost all that.
She,
you know what it's like,
uh,
if you talk to anybody that flies planes,
if you go into a cloud,
you lose your orientation.
It happens in diving too.
It happens when you're surfing.
If you,
if you fall off a big wave and you're getting rolled around and sometimes it can
be hard to tell which way is up,
right?
It can happen.
You know,
guys drive,
drive their airplanes,
they get lost in the cloud.
They drive their airplanes into a mountain or they drive it into the ground
because they don't,
they get disoriented and they lose sight of which way is up and you or you're
underwater and you lose sight of which way is up.
That's what you have to watch out for.
You got to be able to say,
wait a second.
If everything is black around me,
okay,
stop.
Yeah,
let me get oriented.
Let me fix.
Let me check my control panel in the water.
It's real easy.
You got to look for bubbles.
Which way are the button where the bubbles,
the bubbles are going to go up.
And so when you get trapped in that darkness,
these people end up in these situations where everything looks black,
stop.
You're disoriented,
you just can't see.
You don't know the right direction.
It's okay.
Figure out where the bubbles are.
They're going to go to the surface and when they get to the surface,
there's going to be light and you're going to be okay.
Obviously Iris,
she got dragged,
dragged down and disoriented in the darkness and she couldn't figure out that
she had a husband and a son end up family and money and she had all these
beautiful things in her life.
Yeah.
Which a lot of them,
especially if you go full speed in that direction where you don't know which way
is up,
so you're going down.
Even the good things that come in,
you know,
even,
getting paranoid,
it's something good and you're like,
that's bad.
For instance,
for instance,
she's on a trip and Lou Louisville going to go do a speech or whatever and
someone's checking her in the hotel.
Maybe someone was saying,
Oh,
I think that's Iris Chang I saw on TV and said she's thinking,
oh,
it's some nationalists that are coming to get me.
So yeah,
she was absolutely.
So that's something that that I think,
and it's something that for,
for those of us that are not in that situation,
how do you pay attention and observe people and make sure that your friends or
people you know or people that are in bad situations,
how do you make sure that they're getting enough,
that they know how to orient themselves and get back to the surface and get away
from all that horribleness when you approach thing.
And I was talking to Greg,
that's kind of what,
and this just reminded me of it,
when you approach things like that,
you,
you know how like you said you're going down,
if you don't know which way is up,
you're going down a good thing,
you're going to look at it.
That's a bad thing.
Reinforcing my whole direction by the way.
So if you approach it in a way where things that even would be frustrating to
like an everyday person,
if you approach it like good,
um,
you know,
I'm the one to do this thing,
bring the challenge because the challenges are good.
You know,
if that's the approach that will reinforce that way of thinking.
Yes,
yes,
you will be going.
And really,
when you explore darkness,
that's not to embrace the darkness and be dark.
Like I said,
don't become the de,
that's basically you're trying to avoid ignorance.
That's what you're doing.
Because then you got to
know dark contrast.
It's a contract.
Okay,
guess what?
This and for this case,
I mean obviously I,
I pray it never have to read anything as heinous is that again,
ever on the show.
But
that happened,
right?
That happened.
Yeah,
that happened.
We should not,
you shouldn't go through life and not realize that that happened,
that that happened to you,
that human beings said that to other human beings.
And as horrible as it is,
you need to realize that that is a part of our human history.
So that way you can say,
you can,
you recognize and say,
okay,
this is,
this can happen and we need to watch out for it.
And Yeah.
So yeah,
look out for your friends.
Keep them knowing that there's,
keep them know in which direction they're heading in.
And we see someone going sideways,
bring them,
grab them.
Especially with the,
I mean this is kind of a,
it's specific to this story,
but the,
uh,
the drugs,
you know,
when you're taking medicate,
cause that's a pail and men,
it can mess up your pre,
even like how you said when you get off the drugs,
right.
You know,
cause this,
these are all chemical things in your brain need for certain things.
For sure.
So when that part looks sideways,
you can't like reason necessarily with someone,
you know,
they can't reason with,
you can't reason with yourself,
you know,
stuff that would seem obvious.
Hey,
if I,
you know,
walk off this cliff,
it's obvious that's bad.
It doesn't really work that way if like your chemicals are off.
Totally.
So yeah,
you kind of gotta like look out for somebody if you can see that happening.
No doubt.
And it's very,
it's very interesting that the mind is so incredibly durable,
but at the same time it's just totally fragile.
Little,
some little change to the,
to the composition or to the,
to the chemicals that are in or to the thought patterns that are in it.
You know,
it can be really drastic changes on a,
on a person.
Oh yeah.
You ever,
do you ever have a real bad flu and a fever and then you're trying to go to
sleep
and then yes I have.
And it's almost like a mix between dreaming,
hallucinating and like,
because man,
it's like your thoughts are all jumbled up.
Okay.
You want,
you want me to tell you an echo story right now?
Yes.
This will be a stupid echo stories.
So brace yourself.
Awesome.
So I was like 20,
I was 23 years old or something and I was doing the dishes.
Speaking of doing the dishes,
I was doing the dishes and I turned on the water and I didn't see what was
happening.
But this little stream,
a tiny little stream of water had had broken through the pipe at some point in
the handle and it,
and it
started to land on my hand.
Well,
I didn't know that it was water cause it must've been the similar temperature to
what my body was at the time.
And so I see this and it looks for for a quarter of a second,
it looks like my hand is blistering.
It's just,
and it's spreading so rapidly.
And for a quarter of a second I thought to myself,
I'm being attacked by chemical warfare and I'm going to die in the next,
next half a second,
I'm dead.
I think we were,
we were doing some chemical warfare training or whatever.
And so at that moment for about a half a second,
I thought,
I'm about to die.
And it only lasted about that then either unless it was water.
And I said,
but my point is that mentally,
yeah,
what if you know a different situation,
I could get locked into that mode.
And when you see iris going,
hey,
these people are coming after me.
If you get mentally locked in that mode and you start seeing things that are,
that,
that you start imposing or overlaying your reality over actual reality,
you start augmenting reality yourself.
That gets really,
really scary.
Like,
when you think someone's mad at you,
they would add that you think someone's mad at you.
So you're looking for all the little cubes,
you know,
gang,
is this person I met him here or are they not in normal everyday stuff?
You know why he didn't,
why didn't she texted me back quickly and it took her five minutes.
Usually she puts a smiley face,
no smiley face this time.
Yeah,
she's mad.
I know she's met.
Something's wrong.
But yeah.
So yeah,
if you have,
meanwhile they're like,
well,
I don't know what time you're talking about.
Anyway,
speaking of,
uh,
being mad or should I say the opposite of being mad?
So this is what you do.
Take Alpha,
brain alpha,
rainy preworkout performance and strength
and go work out.
See what happens.
That will make a record of that report back.
Yeah.
Um,
actually that's something an iris and her mom both referred to a couple of times
here and they were like,
her mom would say,
you know,
I want to,
I want you to go exercise with me and I,
you know,
I should've put that in the podcast,
but,
but hey,
get the book and read it yourself.
I mean,
that's what you need to do.
I should should've said that earlier.
The raping and King Absolutely.
You know,
get it.
Try and read it when you're in a happy place.
Right?
Yeah.
It's a hard,
hard read.
It's might be the hardest read of any read possible.
I don't know what can be harder than that.
And,
and then the book,
the woman who could not forget by yanging Chang,
which again chronicles her life and it's a really beautiful story and with,
with obviously with a tragic ending and hopefully lessons learned from it.
One of the lessons being be physically be physically active and her mom was
trying to get her to go to the gym with her and work out with her because
there's no doubt it's,
it's,
it's physiologically fact,
physiological fact.
When you work out,
you get endorphins released,
you feel better.
Yeah,
100% yeah.
And it also,
which is good,
I just heard this or no,
it was Joe Rogan.
He had doctor Rhonda Patrick is her name.
She was talking about how working at exercise like is it is one of the more
powerful anti aging.
So you know,
like when you get older,
you know what people,
you know Alzheimer's,
she said not true physical aging,
but for mental agents.
Well that's what,
yeah man,
it's just an all around good deal.
So one time I think I even mentioned,
no,
I didn't mention this.
So one time I,
I might've drank maybe the night before,
this was like maybe a few months ago and I didn't work out for a while.
You know,
I was like,
man,
you know,
immersed in,
I dunno,
work out either way.
It didn't work.
It was,
no,
no.
I got sick and then I got hurt.
So,
okay,
so you cured that with the bottle.
Don't do that
all.
I'm going to make myself feel bad.
No,
you're not actually.
Yeah,
it works.
Yeah.
I probably competent continued story and tell everyone what not to do.
The don't do this.
No,
but there's a happy ending.
So at the,
so boom,
I was over the sickness,
but Andrew was good and I worked in,
I worked up kind of hard to,
and it was weird because I went in the workout thinking,
okay,
I'm glad I get to go work out,
but when,
when you're done,
okay,
I'll admit this.
And I think a lot of people have these thoughts where
maybe you've done something like maybe your routine for whatever reason is going
over and over,
like just real repetitive.
And then after a while,
yeah,
true.
But I'm just saying that sometimes these thoughts of like,
what is all this even mean?
Like what,
what,
what?
Okay,
I'm going to get this and this.
And it's like you think too much after a while he,
and so at the end of life it's like,
okay,
I did all of this.
It just,
I dunno,
it just didn't really,
I was having some of those thoughts.
They weren't like super heavier enough,
but they're in there.
They're like,
okay,
great.
Anyway.
So anyway,
fast forward,
I worked out,
did the workout,
God after it,
textbook definition of God after it.
That was my workout.
I was done in an actually not even done.
I was like in the middle of the workout and I was like,
Dang,
life has straight up meaning like this is what life is and not necessarily the
workout,
just seeing everything I'm doing,
you know.
It was that feeling.
Was that the Alpha brain,
a mustard in to what you're saying is get Algebra.
I'm saying,
I'm saying go workout.
Right.
I like that point.
You got it.
I'm not saying you got it,
but I'm saying if you want to,
yeah,
workout workout for sure.
Change your life.
Take on it.
Big Time.
Yeah.
So the Alpha brain,
that's a neutral pick that helps your memory and whatnot.
So anyway,
if you're going to work out and you want to take some supplements,
which I recommend now,
I was never supplement person.
I tried them but never was really into them.
Or I'd be like,
dude,
you gotta take this,
take the preworkout
performance and strength.
That's what it's called.
Check.
Take that one.
What about shroom tech?
I they pick the shroom tech.
Here's the thing.
He'd been stalking him.
I'm telling you.
See,
watch out.
I haven't been taking shroom tech.
Oh really?
I feel like that's like cheating.
Not Cheating and cheating,
but I mean in Jujitsu,
I mean,
hmm.
I don't feel like it's cheating.
No,
it's not cheating,
but I said you thought it was cheating.
I feel it'll tell you what,
it don't matter.
I mean,
when it comes down to it,
shroom tech or notion of tech.
Bring it.
Yeah.
All right.
Nonetheless,
my original point was,
okay,
working out.
That's the enhancer.
If you want to enhance
the,
you keep,
you keep making me think of more stuff.
Okay.
I'll stop talking.
Yeah,
and then I feel like,
oh,
I should talk about that.
Anyway,
working out as important part that enhances the life.
Yes.
Alpha brain needs supplements,
Alpha brain,
shroom tech,
all these other ones that enhances the workout,
which is the enhancers,
so enhance the enhancer kind of thing.
Anyway,
you liked these things.
You want 10% off,
you don't want to pay full price or maybe do,
I don't know.
But if you don't go on at.com/chocolate 10% off support yourself as well in your
wallet.
I want to talk about Amazon Click through.
That's a good way to support.
That's good because it's like,
you know,
small little thing doesn't cost you anything as you always say.
And um,
you know,
big result,
big support.
Yeah.
I'm going to make the sodium in the fish tank analogy.
I'm going to do it brewery.
Yeah.
Cause I wasn't expecting that at all.
You fill the sodium in water and it blows us small speeds of sodium milk boom
blows.
That's important that you said that.
But what would be more important would be is actually say how you do Amazon,
click through or yeah.
So yeah,
I think you're right about that.
So what you do is you go to [inaudible] dot com a little banner on the side.
There's the,
the UK [inaudible] Dot Co.
Dot.
UK as well.
So Germany,
yes.
Germany and yeah,
I think I'm pretty sure.
Yeah,
it's right there on the side.
Boom.
The,
the,
the main one,
the top one or the one on top is the u s one,
amazon.com.
Oh,
click through there before you do your Amazon shopping.
That's the way to support.
Doesn't cost you anything.
Small action.
Big Reaction.
Be The sodium,
be the sodium
Jocko is a store.
It's called chocolate store
Url Jocko store.com if you want shirts,
discipline equals freedom.
They're all Jocko approved.
The end official.
Go on there.
Look at them.
If you like them to get a shirt for your friend.
Not all Jocko proof cause I didn't approve the pink women's tee shirts.
Yeah,
that's true.
That was not approved.
Right.
That was actually Jocko unapproved.
Yeah.
But we always mute Nian.
Which is kind of part of the game too,
right?
No,
not really.
Okay.
Well,
according to the shirts that we got it,
it apparently,
so that one is technically not Jocko approved,
but it's Jocko unapproved.
So it's,
it's dope nonetheless.
And um,
if you think they're solid,
then yeah.
Get a shirt man.
Support that way.
It's a good way to support,
yeah.
There's some hoodies on there and some rash guards.
Um,
I've beginning to see more and more people with the rash guards.
Yeah.
The rash guards seem to be popular.
At least in victory and my main fitness.
Yeah.
No,
and online as well.
I see you guys doing it anyway.
Look at them.
If you like something,
get something that's a good way to support coming out with a new travel mug.
New and improved new and improved high quality.
Higher Quality.
Yes.
Technically.
Oh,
hold you to,
if you put something hot in their hope makes it,
keeps it hot for a long time.
Hours.
I forget.
Eight hours or something like that.
If cold.
Same thing.
I think cold keeps it long.
Keep it cold longer anyway,
that'll be on the store in two weeks.
Yeah.
Also good way to support and this is actually supporting yourself big time.
It's like a little helper.
It's like when you're benching,
you ever bench pressed too much anymore?
Okay,
so in the event of you benching,
this is what it's like.
If benching is the analogy,
it's like someone spotting you if you need it.
This is what it is.
Psychological warfare you liked it is right.
You get a spot,
you don't need it necessarily every day.
All the time.
Maybe you don't,
maybe don't,
depends on,
you know,
a lot of things,
but if you do need it,
even if you just want it,
hey,
can you spot me?
I might get the,
I'll probably get all Aau,
but you're there,
you know,
just in case that's what this is.
So if you're like,
Hey,
I'm going to,
okay,
this is what it is.
For those who don't know,
but people do know.
But if you don't know,
it's an album you can buy from iTunes with tracks on it for different scenarios
of what weakness.
You'd call it,
moments of weakness,
a weakness,
and you need a little spot,
a little spot and guess was fighting you chocolate.
That's the guy to spot.
Right?
Very dependable,
very reliable,
punctual,
all that stuff will,
to me,
they,
they're like two minutes long.
Give or take.
Yeah.
There's one about,
you know,
before you're going to go and eat.
Yeah.
There's one called sugarcoated lies.
I think that one might be a good one to end of that one,
which is I think one of the more memorable moments,
lines,
whatever.
And you say something about mobilize your will cause your will is stronger than
the will of a donut,
right?
Yeah.
Actual.
And that's that.
When you hear that,
isn't it pretty sad though?
You think yourself,
okay,
I'm not gonna eat this doughnut.
Yeah,
I'm just going to hold my willpower.
But then somehow the the will cause a war is a war of wills,
right?
That's what a warrant is.
So now if you lose that war against the donut means your will is weaker than a
donut donut.
That's not going to happen.
New Warfare Perspective,
you're like,
here's the doughnut and you're like,
your will is stronger than the doughnut and then you eat the doughnut.
You basically said,
I understand that.
Send them this donuts will is stronger than mine.
Don't want to be that person.
And that's your life,
right?
They're putting into perspective anyway.
If you need that spot,
psychological warfare from Jocko Willink,
do a search iTunes and it's also on other things that aren't iTunes,
Amazon music.
It's on,
it's on.
It's no Google play.
I'm pretty sure.
Yeah.
Anywhere that where you can get like MP three music.
Yeah,
exactly.
Call it that anymore.
And B,
is that still a thing?
MP3 music?
Well,
MP three is just the file.
Right.
So remember that used to be MP three players.
Yeah.
Are there still,
yeah.
Technically everything that can play mp3s isn't MP three player.
Yeah.
So yeah,
get a check that one out.
That one's a good and it's a good way to support,
you know,
so that's,
it's a all around circle of support in that way.
Um,
also if you want to get some Jocko white tea,
you can get it.
You can get that on Amazon and when you get it,
I know some people are a little nervous when they try it for the first time.
Just be careful.
You don't want to,
you know,
be in a situation where you,
you're going to go a little bit harder than normal.
Right.
To be ready for that.
When he,
when he bring out the chocolate,
you can get once you've used it before,
you don't have to worry about it.
There's no precautionary wall once you're,
once you're using it,
but when you start,
that'd be careful because you're going to go with that little extra stuff that
you're going to go on.
Attack mode.
Yeah.
It's kind of like when you turn on your car in,
the volume is up a little bit more than you're ready for it.
You're like,
oh,
but then if you do it again,
you're like,
same thing.
Same thing.
So watch out for that.
Jocko.
White tea on Amazon.
Also for international orders.
It's on Ebay.
The official listing is of the Jocko podcast sold by pro resourcing.
So if you're international and you want to get it,
you can do that.
And for those of you that in an in America there it says you see that the
shipping is $100 this is not for you to get it from there.
It's for you to get on Amazon.
If you're in America,
if you're overseas,
the shipping won't show $100 it'll show whatever the cost is.
So I've had a couple people like say,
why is the shipping $100?
It's not,
it's Amazon prime.
The shipping is no cost.
Don't get it from Ebay.
You understand what I'm saying?
You're in the U S if you're in the u s and you made a Jedi getting bit and try
and get it to shipping will show is $100.
You don't get it from Ebay.
You're not supposed to.
We don't want to sell to everybody in America.
We can't handle that.
But we can sell to some people overseas.
Here's what you do Jocko t.com and that has this information on the too,
so it doesn't have that particular information,
but it's a,
it's like a,
just a basic website.
Um,
Dang.
We did a,
I don't know why I didn't mention this before.
It's a basic website.
It's like,
oh,
you're in the u s order from here,
the international order from here,
jock go t.com it's on Jocko store too.
But it's like you got to go to the tab and then go to the page.
You know,
it's,
it's a thing,
but go to [inaudible] dot com if you,
if you're just down for the tea bowls needed too.
There you go.
Yeah.
All right,
well that's all.
Thank you for informing us of that yet another website for those of you that are
asking to get after it.
Mugs,
we're looking at march to be honest with you.
There's so keep looking.
Um,
also,
you know,
uh,
kids,
we've got kids out there running around.
We know that we know that kids are impressionable.
Yes.
Right as they're growing up,
we know that.
We also know that it's hard to be a kid,
right?
You come up against hard times and if you want to help kids get through some
hard times,
you can order this book that I just wrote,
preorder it.
It's called way of the warrior kid.
And this is the weird thing about this book.
Um,
so the other day I was talking to somebody,
it might have even been you.
I was talking to after I got done with edits,
like the final edits,
I was talking to someone.
Yeah.
You know,
I just finished the final edits and I said,
and it's awesome.
And then I felt kind of weird because it's not exactly the most humble way to
describe your work,
right?
Nope.
So I felt that like as soon as I said,
I said,
why am I saying that this book is awesome?
That's not like me.
I didn't walk around and go extreme ownership to bespoke ever taken them all
tree motors.
She was awesome.
I don't say,
well listen to my podcast,
it's awesome.
No,
I don't say that.
I would say,
hey,
you know,
it's,
if you want to listen to it,
if you might be interested in you,
oh,
extreme ownership is good.
You know,
he might get some value out of it.
I'm out running around saying I'm awesome.
Yeah.
For some reason I said,
oh,
this book,
God,
I just got done reading it,
editing it.
It's awesome.
Right.
So I kind of wondered why I said that and then I realized that while I'm
reading.
Okay.
So when I wrote it right,
I wrote it like I was in a 10 year old kid,
but that wasn't me as the guy that's in the book mark these the character,
right?
So when I read it,
it sounds like him.
It doesn't sound like me.
It sounds like him.
So I read the book and I think it's him that wrote it,
this kid,
right.
And I think to myself,
someone said,
how's the book?
And I go,
man,
it's awesome.
So yeah.
Um,
that's what I realized and,
but it is the kind of story that sounds good to read.
Mark,
the kid,
the 10 year old kid,
he's hurting,
right?
He's made fun of,
can't do any pull ups,
doesn't know his times tables,
doesn't know how to swim.
And he's getting bullied like Kenny Williamson,
Dune,
Ken,
you know Kenny Williamson,
we all know the wheel.
Listen,
I'm going to post a picture can,
I haven't introduced Kenny Williamson.
You've yet to the public,
but I'm going to get a out to him.
So he's going through all these trials and tribulations.
But luckily his uncle Jake happens to be a big tough frogman man.
He's going to come and stay with them for the summer.
And when,
Oh,
guess what?
When,
when mark breaks down,
cause he doesn't tell his mom what's going on because his mom just is kind of
mom.
She don't,
doesn't quite,
you know what she's going to say?
Oh right.
You'll learn that stuff.
She can say,
oh honey,
you're a nice boy.
Don't worry about that big bully.
He won't bother you anymore.
No,
no.
My mom actually he will.
Right.
So,
so Martin breaks down kind of,
he won't tell his mom,
but then uncle comms and his uncle is like,
hey we,
you know,
we didn't hang out.
What are you gonna do?
What he or she could do anything.
I get swim breaks down.
So you know what uncle Jake says when mark gets done listing all of his
problems,
lay down,
he says,
good.
All those problems you got,
we can,
we can take care of those problems.
Those are all solvable.
All we gotta do is we've got to work.
We got to study,
we got to train and that's what they do.
So
like I said,
I won't say it's awesome,
but from the perspective of the good,
when you look at it,
if a kid wrote that,
you'd say,
that's a pretty good story.
Got there.
And here's the deal.
A preorder it on Amazon.
Why,
why,
why preorder?
Let me tell you why they got to print it.
Right.
And they're going to print,
they're going to go,
oh well,
you know,
it's the kids walking in kids' books don't sell very well.
So,
um,
you know,
you just will print out 80 copies or whatever,
they'll have their formula and they got their formula.
The formula is not going to work just like it didn't work for Jaguar,
knew it was not going to work.
So the earlier that you preorder it,
the more they'll print the,
then we won't have the shortage,
the scenario that massive screaming in the streets and give us her book.
So preorder it and that'll take care of that while you're doing it.
Pick up raping and King,
Iris Chang.
These will be on the Jocko podcast store.
Click through in the book section and not the store,
[inaudible] dot com Jocko podcast.com books.
And the woman who could not forget,
grabbed that one.
Of course you can also pick up,
you can pick up a couple copies of extreme ownership,
which is the book written by myself and Leif Babin and you know what?
Get a few copies and I'll tell you why.
Because you got to give them to your people on the team,
right?
How many people write to me and say,
I gave this to so and so and they said,
thank you.
Yeah,
this is great.
Get them all in the game.
You know they need it.
If you didn't have it,
would you want somebody to give it to you?
Let me ask you that question.
Yes you would.
It's going to help you out with your game.
So you're going to want them to do that.
And by the way,
if your car,
if you're at your company,
your business and you need some,
some leadership alignment,
you got some little situations going on,
you can check out Leif Babin and we also,
we order a book.
We also have a company called echelon front.
You can that out.
That's what we do.
Leadership and management consulting and that's what we do.
We get companies leadership aligned and on the same page and give them the tools
to lead and win.
Enough said on that.
Also with extreme ownership,
we've got the muster coming muster number two,
May 4th and fifth,
Marriott,
marquis,
New York City,
boom.
Yeah.
Now you know when people talk about the,
people say,
oh,
it's a game changer,
right?
People say that.
I think and and you usually go really changed the team.
They got a new flavor of tortilla chips at the restaurant.
It's a game changer.
No,
that's not a game changer.
It's not description.
Kind of the most common description I've heard of muster number one that we did
in San Diego is game changer.
So
people are getting after it.
Leadership,
management,
health,
Jujitsu,
the good stuff.
Of course I'm going to be there.
Of course Leif Babin he's going to be there.
Obviously Echo Charles going to be there,
JP to Denelle.
You heard him on the podcast,
you're going to see him there and we,
none of us,
none of us would be hiding backstage.
There will not be a backstage.
We're not going to be there.
We will be with you out front talking,
discussing,
solving problems and crushing things.
So come and get that May 4th and fifth and until the muster,
while you're waiting to get to the muster,
you can still kick it with us.
Absolutely.
Cause we're on the interwebs.
We are on Instagram,
we're on Twitter as well.
And if you're gonna be looking for now one that Facebook people
were on that one as well so you can find us there.
Echo is at echocharles and I am at Jocko Willink.
And
finally thanks to everyone for what you do in the military and the police and
the fire department.
Thanks to you all for keeping us safe and in the workforce,
the troopers around the world creating and building what we have,
making the world a better place.
Thank you for what you do.
Grinding and pushing and making things happen.
And again,
I know
that this podcast was hard to listen to.
I know that this episode was
disturbing
and it was hard for me to read.
But again,
to me it is a reminder.
It's a reminder to all of us that darkness is real.
And as I said,
we cannot get lost in that darkness and we can't let the people we know get lost
in that darkness.
And it's a reminder that we have to eliminate
that darkness
and we cannot,
we cannot let evil thrive and permanate permeate.
We can't let it permeate on a mass scale
like Nan king
or on a personal level
like the beautiful Iris Chang.
So get out there,
get out there,
live your life,
get after it,
get after it every day.
Go out there into the world
and shine.
So until next time,
this is echo and Jocko
out.